Hello friends and fuck faces and even fuck faces.
You can be a friend.
Just get it together.
Stop being a fuck face.
Is that possible?
Or continue to be a fuck face if that's your thing,
who might tell you what to do?
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast brought to you by squarespace.
Squarespace is a website that allows you to build websites and allows you to do
it in a way that a moron like me could actually make a website if you could do
the normal functions of,
of using a computer,
like clicking on icons,
dragging,
selecting pictures,
dragging shit,
click and drag it pitch.
Um,
if you do that,
you can,
uh,
you can make an awesome website and it looks incredibly professional.
Twenty bad ass designs,
custom images and content that you provide.
You can,
you know,
you can use your own style,
have to use their images.
They have 24 slash seven super fast email support and they also have a new
ecommerce product so you could start a website and start a store with
squarespace.com really quickly.
And their new product is Galapagos.
It's a new template that will showcase your ecommerce products in a more
interesting way than the typical ordinary grid and galapagos features a dynamic
product mosaic with custom role overstates.
So like if you put your cursor over something,
the image changes,
so if you hover when the visitors hover over each item,
the you can have like a one color,
one black and white and make it fancy and the template is also preset.
With all the content pages you need to have your shop up and running quickly.
Musicians,
it's great for musicians.
You can sell music,
digital downloads and merchandise and you could set up a calendar like really
easy.
It's,
I mean it's,
it's really like,
it can't recommend it.
Enough of her.
No persons that we have recommended this to have come back and said a
squarespace is bullshit.
Everybody that uses it.
So that's a really fucking cool website.
We're going to do some sort of a contest,
a,
I need to get with a square space.
People after the holidays are over and we're gonna,
figure out some sort of a contest to have people create the coolest website with
squarespace blood.
Until then,
you freaks.
Go to squarespace.com and use the offer code all one word Joe,
and then number 12.
That's four December Joe and the number 12.
That's a special offer for gre listeners.
Ten percent discount.
Sign up for a yearly plan and that discount applies to the entire year.
So you use the offer code Joe,
and then number 12,
that's all one word because we're in December.
Get 10 percent off your first purchase on new accounts.
You freaks and we're also brought to you by one 800 flowers.
This is the holiday seasons,
ladies and gentlemen.
Christmases here.
I think [inaudible].
Is it era past?
How's that worked?
I think it's over.
It's over.
You can still buy someone flowers.
It doesn't have to be.
Hanukkah flowers are just cool.
They're nature's masterpieces.
They're beautiful,
they're cool,
they smell good and they make checks feel better.
For some strange reason,
if a dude buys you flowers,
you might want to have to sit down and I would talk with him though,
is reality in a way?
No,
no.
Just let them,
you know,
it's known to be.
Need to be scared.
Brian,
you contributing to fear.
Just tell him,
hey man and roses are horrible.
Like get some other flower girls didn't are done with roses I think.
Not think so.
Every time I get roses for a girl,
they're like,
what are you like 1992 just talking to you.
Yeah,
probably one 800 flowers has a.
They have a Christmas centerpiece that you can get.
The Christmas centerpiece is this huge thing.
Like can you go to one 800 flowers and see their Christmas centerpiece.
So all of these beautiful flowers are cool as fuck.
I mean it's really weird what beauty is when you stop thinking about it.
Like why are we drawn to particular plants and to particular sunsets and
sunrises.
Like what is it about beautiful things that's so appealing and attractive and
what it does to us.
That sense of too weird.
So weird aspect of being a human that I don't think animals share living.
They do.
They just can't talk about them.
I know I've used these guys a lot.
By the way,
Joe.
I've used one 800 flowers at time and they are a great company.
Yeah,
they have a great reputation and the flowers are beautiful and expertly crafted
by local florists and hand delivered to your door so they have like a whole
network of people that they use all over the country that are excellent florists
so they get it to you quickly filled with red roses and white lilies and more
this bright seasonal centerpiece.
It's accented with fragrant evergreens,
pine cones,
and topped off with a red velvet ribbon and candles.
If you want to convince a girl that you're gay kid or this.
This is what I love and I would love it if you got me.
Mike got me this and I was so happy.
Who's Mike?
You know the guy in the office and I really like.
Anyway,
I wonder if they have like a service because this would be cool to always have
fresh flowers that it's kind of like they just automatically send you like a
thing of flowers every week.
Sure.
He could do that.
I know businesses do that.
They have deals with florists,
you know,
some businesses that really appreciate flowers.
They work out deals,
smart move.
Yeah.
You know,
people love that shit.
If you're in that business,
like say if you're a dentist or something like that,
you know,
people will like,
they'll actually enjoy your place better if you have flowers there.
It was bizarre,
but it's true.
Uh,
there is no better place than one.
800 flowers.com.
If you want to get some flowers,
that's the place to go.
One,
800 flowers.com.
Go to one 800 flowers.com from your desktop or mobile device.
Click on the radio microphone in the upper right corner and enter J R,
e dot.
That's one 800 flowers.com.
And Enter J R,
he freaks all core or you can call them,
you can call one 800 flowers.
And mentioned jre and they'll be like,
what are you talking about?
They also have a fucking Weirdo to have same day delivery,
which is great.
For last minute they couldn't be more awesome.
So one 800 flowers.com and we're also brought to you by on it o n n I t and I
just noticed that on it has some new power food.
Shit.
I haven't even looked into this all in one daily Greens mix.
I was taking a daily Greens miss mix for awhile,
but I ran out of it and I got lazy but it was good to like add to water and just
make sure making sure that you get your phytonutrients,
your,
your vegetables.
Oh,
because of the website more as move movement.
They did a good job.
Whoever does this website,
it's on point on.
It has a variety of things.
The website,
the best way to describe it is it's a human optimization website.
We sell kettle bells and battle ropes,
protein powders.
That's from the finest hemp we.
We sell blenders to make smoothies.
We just sell all shit than we like shit that we think is good and ask for the
supplements.
If you use the code named Brogan,
you will save 10 percent of any and all supplements.
Are you folks?
That's enough for this Lee campus here.
At least gentlemen.
Cue The music prime.
Well again,
experience Joe Rogan podcast,
the camp as been side smiles layer.
You were on Fox News once upon a time.
Made it in there.
Did it smell like sulfur?
It's about like souls.
Why are the girls that worked there so fucking hot cause they know how to hire
people.
Apparently this insane.
They're way too high.
It's not fair because men will agree with them.
Just to hope that they will say yeah and high five you.
You'll change your whole philosophy and there's.
You can find clips on youtube where people just put together every time they
open their legs during the various segments.
Praise the Lord there too hot.
It's unfair.
That's like hypnosis.
You know some of those.
What was that woman's Megan?
What's her name?
The really angry when Meghan Kelly,
she's so fucking hot.
It's ridiculous.
Whereas she show me some Meghan Kelly.
This is a.
Oh,
this is.
Yeah.
This is really cool.
Play this because this is how I found out about Lee,
but back it up.
So I'm sure you guys are going to have a lot more jokes for the rest of the
campaign here.
They just keep going.
Can I.
Can I just ask a question?
Sure.
What,
what is Fox News?
It's just a parade of propaganda and that it's just that it's just a festival of
ignorance.
What people did in Iraq.
Come on.
This is ridiculous.
What's the point of this?
Go outside.
Go,
go.
Hug Me.
Well,
you love your family.
You know
snooze.
All right.
Thanks.
Is the best.
Watch this.
Keep it on.
It was the best part.
We're also captain Kirk this morning because it's Saturday morning and fun.
Greg cushiest job in the world.
Yeah.
Look who just beamed aboard right now.
The ladies from the Star Ship Enterprise.
Hello.
Welcome.
This four hot chicks in an outfit.
I just wrote a new book on Captain Kirk and the way he was able to.
Woo.
Beautiful.
It's a book about Kevin couldn't get laid,
but come on the fictional character captain kirk too,
by the way.
Not
Even William Shatner tell all book I was in the green room within.
I could not figure out why there were these women there.
I had no idea that you just.
It was almost like it was scripted because you said that and then they showed
you was the most inane,
stupid piece of shit.
I didn't even know that was coming up next.
Oh my God.
It was perfect.
You couldn't have been.
What if they went to some series news and fucked,
you know,
he wanted to.
You could see in his face as he read the teleprompter,
he was like,
all right,
we're going to get out of this and go ah shit.
And it's like completely proved your point.
Like right away,
like,
come on man.
How did Kirk get laid?
He could skip.
Really wrote did he got laid.
The writers made him get laid down.
A real guy.
Jesus fucking aliens to wars going on.
The entire banking system had to be bailed out by taxpayers' money.
He was running aliens.
They just wanted to see what a human cock was like.
That's how he got laid.
Do you think they have like a bunch of shit that they will throw out there,
like beach balls to distract and they get like they get it from the CIA every
week.
Star Trek check.
You just have to send it this way.
We want you to talk about this week like Zap the American mind.
No,
no,
no.
You know what I mean?
I don't believe that it is.
I don't believe.
I think I tend to think that it's more in competence than conspiracy.
I conspiracy ratings.
They don't actually care about the news.
They only care about ratings.
They don't care about the news,
but I think in general,
like even the most of what we think of as being this big gigantic conspiracy
with our government and the media is more in competence and Horesh behavior than
anything.
Just they're prostitutes.
Prostituted themselves out because that's where they got the good assignments.
They got to the good places.
They got the big ratings.
I mean,
you don't get to that
point.
You don't get to that job unless you've proved yourself a faithful foot soldier
to whatever their messages generally,
you know,
they're not,
you're not gonna get hired on.
Yeah.
And even guys that used to be Kinda like rebels,
like Geraldo Rivera rather rivera was kind of a rebel at one point.
He was the guy that had Dick Gregory on TV and film for the first time I got in
a fistfight at a KKK rally,
I think on a show.
If someone hit him in the head with a chair,
they might not even been trying to hit him.
It was just a melee and I think a chair went flying and he got his nose broken
and he was fucked up.
But then he was so excited,
so excited to have actual cut on his face.
I'm a tough guy.
Like what's.
He was supposed to box frank stallone or something crazy like that too,
a long time ago.
Oh my God.
They might have actually done it.
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure,
but he's a wild dude,
or at least he was a wild dude,
you know,
and now he's just like Fox News puppet.
It's weird when you see the,
the ones that actually stick
to their guns,
they don't last long.
I mean Cenk Yoga lasted two months at Msnbc before he,
before he needed to leave.
Amber Lyon is another one that left because her Bahrain story actually you
mentioned Bahrain,
uh,
CNN,
she brought it back to them and said this is what's going on by rain.
But they were doing ads talking about how great Bahrain was and wouldn't play or
segment.
Yeah.
She,
she's
podcasts before and she explained it all to us and it's,
it's so hard to believe that what we consider to be like a shining,
revered institution of news,
like CNN has just a bullshit propaganda wing that they,
they're capable of that kind of behavior.
If she's telling the truth.
I don't know.
I wasn't there.
I assume she is.
She seems very honest.
I don't know anybody else's side on the other side.
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck is really going on,
so I probably shouldn't comment on what CNN did or didn't do,
but I know for a fact they're not reporting a lot of shit.
We're putting a lot of shit and I feel like all of these networks,
that mainstream media,
it's a very small box of accepted thought that is allowed on them.
It's not.
They're not going to go either very far to to either side or outside that box.
No,
it's not
really the news and that's one of the more interesting things about the internet
is because the Internet now,
there's all these sources that are like more real news,
like they're telling you about shit that's going on that you might not have
known.
I could just see this thing about the CIA dude who's a fake CIA guy for like 10
years.
No,
here,
let me pull it up when I can.
If I can get a chance here,
but I think that what we're seeing now with the Internet and with just this
incredible influx of like daily information about life,
about science,
about the real reality of
people don't.
People are waking up.
I mean it is slow.
It's a slow,
painful process,
but uh,
it's.
People are waking up.
I mean,
I mean with Syria,
that was the first time I've ever seen our war machine and our media war machine
get it into high gear and people were like,
I don't think we need to bomb the shit out of Syria.
Listened and yeah,
no shit,
right?
That,
we were talking about that the other day.
At the
first time that,
that really did happen.
The public said,
fuck,
this guy went,
oh yeah,
Syria,
we don't need to go there.
Come on.
I mean,
we were just saying we just wanted to see what you guys thought.
So sweat this dude,
this guy,
the EPA is highest paid employee and a leading expert in climate change deserves
to go to prison for at least 30 months for lying to his bosses and saying that
he was a CIA spy working in Pakistan so that he could avoid doing his real job
says the federal prosecutors.
So the dude,
how slick is this cat?
He tells his people at the fucking.
He goes,
he's works for the EPA,
the highest paid climate expert.
And they go,
well,
we want you to do a lot of studies on climate change.
Like,
listen,
I would love to work for the CIA is a protecting America.
Meanwhile,
he was just making it up,
but he did it for the longest time,
like this guy built them out of a million dollars over a decade.
I say more power to them.
There's a drift in the system and use it again.
It's like it's more than competence than it is anything.
It's more human horesh behavior.
It's greed than it is for example.
But I have to work for the CIA.
What can I tell you?
My hands are tied.
You have to just invent that you're a CIA operative.
How many fakes
I operators out there like dudes are trying to impress chicks and it's amazing.
Especially with homeland,
it's probably jumped up quite a bit.
Can you prove to us that you're seeing.
I would love to,
but it's top secret.
Have you would have to be sequestered and that's the thing.
Look,
I can't.
I'm working for the.
I'm trying to save America.
I know it looks like I'm on facebook 23 hours a day.
But uh,
yeah,
they checked his cell phone like texting,
like 20 different chicks.
What's going on man?
You weren't really working on climate change.
It was just getting mad cash.
Just bawling every night going strip clubs for all parties at the house.
Uh,
it's a lot of you porn,
but you point is actually a front for a CIA website.
So making sure that the really dark stuff doesn't.
I watched the,
you know,
the ain't no.
We have to allow a certain amount.
I am horrified by the gaping.
If we don't allow it,
then we're gonna lose a lot of the people that would be with us against this
child.
My job to measure the diameter of the gate because if it gets beyond a certain
point,
if we start getting officers like we gotta cancel the program,
they've seen some of the,
first of all,
think of the size of an ostrich egg and that's nothing compared the size of some
of these people's butts.
You know that they like least stretch them out in these videos.
Have you been to IFEC Joe Website?
He fucked.
No,
it was all just really horrible shit.
It's like that.
It's like so many pink socks,
like people getting stocks coming out,
girls pooping while having sex.
Well,
that's the weird thing is not just that that exists,
it's that we kind of are not even a little bit surprised at that exists because
we all know that the natural tendency of human beings is to escalate.
We just escalate and if a guy can put it in,
your mouth is going to go.
What about your,
but just even know why he wants to do it.
What other holes do you have to offer?
I mean when,
when people are,
uh,
you know,
obsessed with anything,
whether it's sex or technology or whatever,
whatever it is,
you're going to try to take that thing to the highest level.
Like they're making a mustang.
Now there's a mustang you could buy from the factory.
It's 670 horsepower.
That's ridiculous.
That's absolutely insane.
It's a shelby gt,
500.
It's got like 668 something horses.
Where do you use that?
Just the salt flats on the salt flats.
It goes 200 miles an hour.
It's a mustang.
It's one of the craziest things that anyone's ever offered for sale because it
doesn't even handle good.
I mean it's really like an old muscle car.
It has something called a live axle,
which is essentially like a log that keeps your wheels on it.
So just one big fat.
They don't do that anymore.
They do independent real suspension so that when you hit bumps,
your car adjusts.
Our tendency is to see how far it can go.
I mean look at our nuclear bomb arsenal like w,
what was it?
100 nuclear bombs would destroy the planet and we've got like several thousand
just in case.
Just in case you bitches know.
We're serious.
Serious.
Yeah.
We're weird.
People are weird and I think go to the end.
We escalate things.
If you know for gambling,
you don't know if you become a blackjack addict,
you don't pay for $5 a hand.
You want to go to 50,
you want to go to 100.
I got 500 really feel that fucking crazy rush and they tell you that like once
you get addicted to that rush,
you can't take that back.
Like you can't go from $5,000 to betting a dollar and getting thrilled.
You won't care.
You get angry at yourself,
you know,
it's a weird thing that happens to you.
We were,
we're like meant to escalate.
So you know,
you see those gaping videos and you're like,
Yep,
I got it.
I see whether they are just makes sense.
We're fucking crazy.
I think it like the,
the whole anal thing always like I always wondered why people wanted to do anal,
but some people like it.
Yeah.
But I could.
I could see if.
Have you ever been with one of those girls where you're like,
their pussy does feel like very,
like there's a lot of extra baggage or like room in there.
I mean it's just like,
you know when you have a larger vagina,
it's just like almost wow.
I would imagine the vagina,
it's just like penises,
Brian.
They vary in size.
Just if I was married to a girl like that,
I would get all right.
We're doing anal more often than you don't say it like that.
You're going to clean your room or we're taking away your allowance.
You wouldn't say it like that or I know that,
but you know that.
I'm not going to say why because I'm saying to you,
if you're saying it to hurt,
you tend to be somebody who you're not to.
To her,
I'd get her like one of those centerpiece baskets from 100 flowers and come on
down the car.
Your Vagina's joke answer.
It's the number one thing when 100 flowers is used for anal makeup,
for Anal and to comfort women with enormous vagina.
You have a special on the anal basket.
No passcode.
So we get an Anal Fox news girls.
Why they're so hot.
Those girls are so God damn hot.
Like I don't want to marry them.
I don't want to have relationships with them.
But if I was a single man I would be very attracted to those angry bitches
or the weathermen in La.
I just think there's.
So there's so,
like aggressive.
I don't know if they're so strong.
They're so stern in their opinion.
Yeah.
Most of them are not dumb.
It has nothing to do with dme.
No.
Just said about those mean bitches just because I'm a glutton for punishment.
But if you,
um,
like when you're on that show,
like what,
what,
what is it like when you're in that studio,
does it feel weird?
Do you feel like.
Well that's the thing.
It's like
some just seem like they're doing their job.
I mean,
yeah,
they worked for the evil empire,
but they don't,
they're just like whatever gets them through the day.
Oh I need to say this thing and this thing and then when we wrap for the day,
like,
so I had to remind myself why it was important for me to do that.
I like read,
read an article about how million people died in Iraq.
I mean this was,
this was several years back and uh,
and you know,
cause you don't want to fuck up the show.
Like I felt like I needed to do and I only wanted to be on there once.
I was like having me on.
It's going to be a one time thing
it says yet,
dude,
it was,
if you were like a publicity whore and I know you're not,
but there'll be an awesome move.
I mean it worked out.
I never thought it was 7:00 AM on a Saturday.
I truly thought the only people,
and this was four or five years ago,
we're not.
Everything on the news went online.
I truly thought that the only people seeing it would fox news fans at 7:00 AM on
a Saturday and instead it went up online and viral and all that shit.
Man,
if you got something relevant to say,
the Internet will catch it.
Yeah.
They'll find it and they'll put it out there to go back.
That girl like standing and sitting there with her legs open.
This is insane.
I just want to point something out of how we are so weird like as a culture that
this is a part of normal everyday office life.
Like we've got to make some decisions here.
Like look at this woman.
She's showing everything but her vagina.
I mean her knee is just strategically blocking her labia.
Her legs are wide open and she's hot as fuck.
Now here's the thing.
If you put the Kyron right in front of the vagina,
then everybody would know the news.
Exactly.
We'd be a very informed country and women would get angry at you if you knew the
news.
Oh,
you were looking at her vagina and you read the fucking news.
Huh?
Like she,
like,
it's just weird that they get to dress like that.
Like she's completely wearing come fuck me pumps back that up again.
Let's,
let's dissect this.
Look at her like her shoes.
Those are like,
I want to go out and get sexy shoes.
There's a not comfortable by any stretch of the imagination.
They show most of your foot.
Her,
almost her entire legs are exposed.
Mean you imagine if a guy was sitting there like that.
You know how bizarre that would be if there was a show where a guy was sitting
there in a tiny,
tiny kilt and you know that you could,
if he moves his left knee an inch to the right,
you're going to see his cock for sure.
And,
and they also have like an ejection button that slings them into the
stratosphere at once.
They hit 35,
but you hit an age in an age limit.
They disappeared on poor girls.
That's a fixed.
You had some kind of irritation down there.
So.
Well I think Sarah Pailin brought the DM MILF back.
So maybe,
uh,
maybe we'll move in that direction,
but I don't think she actually brought it back.
She brought it back for a little bit.
But now people are,
like,
you say too much crazy shit.
Guilt,
guilt.
You forgetting the grandma.
She's a qrf.
You don't want to say that though because it'll fuck with you.
Dig.
It's creepy.
Yeah.
Is Okay.
But not so much.
It's just weird that we have these odd standards of sexual attire in the
workplace and not just in the workplace but on television,
like on television,
promoting this strange propaganda machine and just really hot girls with their
vaginas.
Hanging out with explosions and hot girls.
Okay.
I can't pay attention to whatever the fuck she say when she see her thighs.
Oh my God.
If I see that girl go,
wow,
I wish she liked me.
You know?
Especially if you're lonely and you know,
you're not married or anything.
Dude,
that guy.
That guy is like 12 times he size.
Yeah.
It's rob for its fat brother.
And what other shirts has like Kimbera man that from the ground up,
skirt,
skirt.
It's totally enough score there.
Panning from the vagina up.
It's off center just slightly.
He's trying to show off his two though.
You gotta give him credit.
Who's.
Well,
you know it's got to go to war.
You know,
you've got to get a respect.
He doesn't give.
Fuck.
The only way I'm gonna get this one is if I let her know I don't give a fuck.
Here's my gut.
I'm not trying to cover myself up.
I'm staying an extra straight.
I'm spreading my legs wide.
Look at that.
Package is going for the.
Don't give a fuck points.
It might be a fat fuck,
but I'll fight.
You should add a fact because I like to live that good life.
That's what he's saying.
Like there's playlist of all the different ones.
Was that one the one that you just showed?
That's a Fox.
Went to the redhead.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
That one.
The blonde.
That was screens.
I know who she is.
That's the one.
She's been on these things before.
They're all hot though.
They're beautiful.
It's weird,
but it's just such a dirty trick.
One.
I'm not,
especially like if you're married and you know when you're trying to be
monogamous,
you're going to look at sex in a different way because you look at like a girl
that's like super,
super hot and you go,
oh,
I could never get that.
If you're single,
if you're delusional,
you'd be like,
man,
if I just ran into her at the right place right time,
maybe this could happen.
So it's a different thing.
So it's the.
There's a wistful,
almost romantic way.
You look at the Fox News girls if you're married
on the,
on the on the same note.
It's like when I went out when a hot celebrity like gets divorced,
there's something inside the most loser of guys.
It's like now I got a shot.
You know,
like,
like Angelina Jolie gets divorced and people are like,
okay.
They think all I gotta do.
I'm just,
their guys are so fucking delusional.
They feel like all they gotta do is be at the right place,
the right time.
You know,
maybe she goes to the car shop because your wipers broken and she wants to try
to fix it herself.
And you know,
I get to impress her by my knowledge of windshield wipers and she realized I'm
just a regular guy and sometimes girls will.
Jesus Christ.
Look at this.
She actually pulls her skirt up.
Look,
Bam.
Like,
oh,
pulling it up.
How dare you,
you dirty bitch.
Oh my God,
look how she sits.
It's perfect posture.
It's kind of like going back to when you were like really young,
looking at like jc penny's lingerie catalogs,
like when we're tense and you wonder why people that Watch Fox News are idiots.
I mean,
not that a lot of networks aren't,
but you know,
they did that study that people have watched Fox News.
No less about what's happening in the world.
The people watching no news at all.
I believe that.
I love that.
That makes sense.
It'd be all.
You're gonna,
you're gonna.
Find out about captain Kirk's love life.
So these are two regular guys.
Is ABC,
ABC as regular girls.
ABC is more probably geared towards women that don't want to be threatened
in the background.
He's never seen this video to be naked.
No,
it's just hammered in the shorts.
Well Christy,
they are the whole neighborhood knows the boy jumped out of a fucking second
story window and fell.
Oh my God.
That's funny.
Yeah.
If you leave the fucking camera on long enough,
people catch the craziest shit ever.
Did you see any of the,
like the snow storm driving footage son you got jacked?
Yes.
Yeah.
Snow storms all throughout the country that been getting these nutty snow and
ice storms.
Yeah.
What is that man?
It's,
it should be.
It's unfair.
I mean,
I don't want to say that pretty girls shouldn't be able to get a job.
They should,
but it shouldn't be exclusively pretty girls telling you about important shit
week to week.
We're not paying attention to the message.
No,
not at all.
But that's the thing.
If you see an ugly girl on the news,
you're like,
that girl knows her shit.
Right?
She fought her way to the top.
There's just something about,
um,
like,
uh,
like I said,
like those Fox News women that like the one you were talking about before the
show started who argued with someone about Santa Claus being white.
Meghan Kelly.
Apparently said very authoritatively that Santa Claus is white.
Yeah,
she's very authoritative.
Always.
A lot of those gals are.
But there's something like four Beta men,
especially for men that are weak and beaten down by life.
The ultimate fantasy is that this woman accepts you.
The ultimate fantasy is that she's impressed by you and accept you because she's
so hard ass.
She's so obviously beautiful,
but also so hard ass that there's this,
there's this,
uh,
you know,
when she's around you,
you want to like mark obamacare.
You want to just start making fun of it like you.
He'll write specific just to make her happy.
Girls.
Yeah.
Just get in,
get in to get in and just talk to her.
He asked white had.
Goddamn righty.
Yes.
Show me one picture with Santa.
It's black.
It wasn't drawn by a black guy.
So yeah,
we were saying the sand is probably Siberian prolix.
Chinese
Greenpeace just put out a video of Santa,
like in a melting height.
And the point is that,
and he's saying how the Arctic is melting or whatever.
And it's pretty creepy video.
Well,
it is know,
but it's also so hard.
Let's face it,
he's gonna fall through the ice before the.
A little extra weight.
It's so fought hard,
fought hard to fucking figure out when when it comes to climate and climate
change,
it's hard to figure out why people have this weird need to be on a team one side
of the other and now they have this weird name.
I was in an
exercise class and someone brought up just out of nowhere,
some guy brought up climate change and this young guy who's,
you know,
could have been 1:25 years old,
starts going.
Climate change as always happened.
It's a part of life.
It's a part of the cycle of earth.
It's always gotten warm and always gotten cooler.
Yeah.
Over a million years.
Never.
Sure.
Every other time it's happened over a million years.
Now it's 100,
but it's also like,
how much research have you done?
He was there,
he was there,
he wasn't what he was saying.
What he was doing is just like going against liberal ideology right away.
I'm on team B team
business,
you know,
I'm a.
I'm a no nonsense business sort of a guy and it's just this need to be taken
seriously and so,
you know,
he and I had this conversation.
I said,
well,
it's absolutely changed throughout history.
It's without a doubt,
but it's also very possible and most likely that we're changing it right now and
even more rapidly than normal.
Something to be concerned with.
And like he had this look on his face like he can't have.
I was giving them both options.
I was given them the option to write and I was also saying,
you know,
the climate,
a control site and you're giving it in an easy way.
Like this seems like we don't have to argue what do I.
don't give a fuck.
I have no invested interest or no,
no vested interest in being right about climate change.
I've done zero work in it.
If it was my chosen field,
then maybe perhaps my ego would be attached to climate change like Egypt.
But yeah,
he just snowed in Egypt for the first time at 100 and something years the other
day.
Snowden.
Cairo,
yeah.
I was in Illinois a month ago.
When they had the most tornadoes they've ever had in November or whatever it
was,
sitting under a bridge or one of those
going to Chicago in January.
It'll be.
That'll be fine.
Brian.
I got to get you to put that on the calendar.
Okay.
That's the Chicago theater.
January 24th with a beautiful and talented Ari Shaffir who goes cold as fuck.
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
Fuck.
I heard rfcs moving back.
Oh,
you have to do is just moved to New York.
Yeah.
You get one winter there and you're like,
oh,
this is a place where I can go where I don't have to do this.
That was on a couple shows with them,
but I thought he was just visiting.
Yeah,
he stayed there for awhile.
I think it helps comedy a lot.
He just decided that we needed a new environment needed to really mix it up.
So we got an apartment there.
80 five right now?
Yeah.
In La,
you know,
New York's fucking fantastic.
It's huge.
It's gigantic.
It's filled with all sorts of interesting stuff and it's more museums per capita
than any city in the country and it's a.
it's a thought hub for sure,
but it's also like you're also beat your brains out,
but being surrounded by people like that all the time,
just
don't necessarily think that's good for you.
Yeah,
I like it.
Yeah.
Some people love it.
My manager loves it.
He fucking,
he wouldn't live anywhere else.
It keeps.
Keeps me angry.
Yeah.
He goes,
I love the energy of the city.
I'm like,
I just,
I want to be similar way here.
Like birds Chirp and I just see the wind blows gently through the trees.
I don't hear anybody talking.
That's what I need,
but I think there's just because of around such large numbers of people,
I want to have a balance of that.
Like with the UFC or the,
you know,
doing comedy shows.
Yeah.
Get all these people.
I want to balance that out with just some.
No people time
you,
your,
your job is to watch people beat each other's heads and you don't need it on the
subway and the sidewalk.
Enjoy watching violence outside of my job.
Yeah.
Well there's not.
I don't think it's any more violence in New York and there was no la now.
I just meant angry people.
I think in fact,
probably New York is more open minded,
you know,
a lot of people don't think that they think of California as being the most open
minded,
but I think quite honestly that there's something that you miss when you were in
cars all the time.
You don't interact with people.
That's.
I think that's.
It's actually what it is.
I think that it,
unless you're truly rich,
rich in New York City and taking a cab everywhere you are,
you're,
you're interacting with every type of person all day long
and even if you are rich that you have to take a cab,
like maybe for that one brief moment,
you know you're in a different environment,
but you'd get out of the cab,
you're going to walk right and you're gonna walk for a block or two and it's
going to be a fucking billion people.
There's experiences like that where you're walking down New York,
you don't get that anywhere else.
It's not parking lot of the office to the house garage.
It's not like mall,
he didn't park your car in the mall,
you walk in holding hands like the other Dr Seuss families,
this fucking hordes of people walking up and down and it's weird people and
homeless people and you gotta step over bumps and you know,
you got to see everything.
You got to see the whole fucking broad spectrum.
Set it again.
Yeah,
I mean I think la is very,
very kind of liberal or left wing,
but there's a lot of apathy because I feel like it's just too nice here.
It's just too nice and happy is definitely not enough.
Whether were cocky as fuck.
There's no seasons.
Yeah.
They don't have to deal with weather.
Whether it's real,
you know,
you need to know that you're on a planet to change all the time.
We didn't in the cold smacks in the face.
Yeah.
We have like,
we found like an area of the game where we got to God code.
Come over here.
Oh God,
code over here.
It doesn't rain.
It doesn't.
Snow never gets cold.
The worst of the wears a Hoodie,
like that's the worst you have to wear here as a Hoodie.
He just hit abb,
left,
right,
right.
Nice weather forever.
It would do everybody a lot of good if it snowed here every year would
straightened a lot of fucking fucking crazy ice storm.
Tornado just once a year.
Just snowed
and God fucking cold and brained and just let you know that like,
look,
okay,
you ain't shit bitch.
I think there's a reason why people that live on the actual coast itself,
um,
have a more humble and more laid back sort of vibe to them.
Like beach towns.
Like if you go to Huntington or Venice or Santa Monica,
you have like a more laid back sort of a vibe.
And I think part of that,
it's like you're faced with the reality of the ocean,
right?
Like you ain't shit
how massive this is.
You standing there next to this insane thing that you can't even go in.
And if it comes over you,
you're fucked.
And it does it every now and then you just playing Russian roulette that it
doesn't do it today.
One day though,
the earth moves
middle somewhere and a fucking seven mile high wall of water just watches a
hundred miles in all the way to fucking receipt a kills everybody.
Yeah,
that happened
all the time.
Everyone's well,
it's nice to see the earth fight back.
Just be like,
look,
I'm still in control.
Well,
just to let you know,
like this is a,
you haven't locked this thing down at all.
You have zero control over the weather.
He have zero control of asteroids.
He has zero control,
super volcanoes and all the other shit.
Like a micro organisms could kill us anytime they want it.
We can't be scanned.
So I meant sorry,
I meant um,
was there any negative repercussions when you did that?
Fox News thing?
Uh,
yeah,
and wiped out my entire career,
uh,
kind of switched.
I mean it was okay because I was kind of looking to make the switch anyway,
but it switched me from a completely college touring comedian that was basically
all my income was college touring and I had a largely apolitical,
largely clean,
but not exactly clean,
but a act.
And I was kind of switching more to politics and Karen more about that shit.
And after this clip went viral,
it was the first thing every activities board looks up on Google.
And uh,
I've,
I did 500 colleges.
I've probably done 10 in the past four years.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
And for folks who don't know,
college has pay a lot of money.
Like a lot of guys when they're first coming up,
like that's number one goal.
The
first goal is to get a college agent,
get an Naca,
do good at the convention.
And then started doing college tours.
That was a ton of money like you could do.
Yeah.
Well you're a nobody.
You can make two grand a show in the nineties.
Yup.
Yeah.
I knew I was a nobody,
you know,
like not even.
Yeah.
I guess the nineties,
early nineties it was,
it was still like the early two thousands.
It's a good,
it's a really good place.
Some guys get in a rut unfortunately.
And they become just college comics.
Right.
Which is why I was looking to change because you get stuck there,
don't you?
Totally do.
And people don't realize it,
but when you go to Naca,
like they offer you the chance to showcase,
but they would really like you to be like as as clean as possible.
They don't want you doing any Bradley really controversial Shit.
They want you to be able to like they a put you on.
They don't want to worry about getting any people that are offended that we're
gonna write letters,
emails,
people.
People still have this impression of colleges from like,
I don't know,
the seventies and eighties where they likely,
oh yeah,
there are these activist hubs and everything now cause kids don't give a fuck.
Just a lot of Virginia
in college,
which is really weird.
Joey Diaz and I did the University of Miami,
I think it was going to assume at some university in my final couple of years
back and we were in the middle of something and I remember I said I saw so many
people that didn't know what the fuck I was talking about.
I go,
how many people here are virgins?
you don't have to raise your hand.
I could just give me a little of this.
Just lift your hand yet.
There was a lot.
A lot.
It was and I was like,
you guys don't even know what I'm talking about.
Like,
oh my God,
you're in college.
You guys have to fuck.
Yeah.
Get it over with.
This is a big part of life and you haven't even started it yet.
That was your game.
Probably though.
You're at Miami,
University of Miami.
You guys need to fuck.
So we're having a party.
Yeah,
but even if they know what you mean when you say a joke about fucking they
probably a little sad.
They're not doing it,
so they get so mad at so many different things.
People are looking forward to
protesting in a lot of ways in colleges.
They're trying to stretch out their protest muscles and you know,
sometimes misguided,
sometimes guided.
It's a lot of it is done in the correct mindset.
Whether or not it's the correct idea to protests in the first place,
but you could have a joke about anything that someone finds misogynistic and
next thing you know,
there's a giant letter that's written about you,
you know,
from one of the people that attended your college show and then you have to deal
with that.
Yeah,
I actually went to one where they told me beforehand they go,
okay,
so don't curse and uh,
don't,
don't.
This is the best.
Don't mention drugs or alcohol.
And it was like,
what order a clown then.
All right,
you don't want a comedian if you're like,
act like half of life doesn't exist.
I remember someone said there's a,
like a stock joke to Jews walking to a bar.
They buy it silly,
right?
Right.
Someone said it and this guy comes up and says,
I was very offended by that Jewish joke.
I go,
that's the most ridiculous shit ever.
Listen to what he said to Jews walk into a bar and they buy it.
That means they purchased these.
They have a lot of money and they purchased businesses.
Like,
what?
What's about that?
How could you be offended?
But I like that they're looking to be offended.
People are looking to be,
to just hear they're buzzword.
That is totally a buzzword because that joke is,
it's not about cheap.
It's about guys who purchased a bar.
It's so stupid.
It's like,
what are you saying?
It's bad to be a bad ass businessman.
I'm so confused why you're upset.
But it's still,
they're not really upset there.
So looking at me upset and there's,
there's a difference between someone who's actually like protesting something
that's real and someone will get upset at nonsense and it's fucking.
It's really frustrating.
Like there's a um,
there's,
something's going on today.
There's a female protest her.
Did you see this thing?
And she's a,
she got arrested for sexual assault because she kissed or a riot policeman's
helmet and there's a picture of her doing it.
It's,
it's really weird,
man.
And it's in Italy,
my people,
you fucking dummies.
How dare you,
how dare this girl is beautiful.
And she's pretty and she's kissing this helmet and they arrested her for sexual
assault.
Like that's not,
that's not the correct use of power.
That's abusive
power in the UK,
they were prosecuting a protest because he called a police horse.
Gay.
Look at that gorgeous girl,
so pretty and she's got glasses.
Sexual assault were Mexican.
I think he's well defended against the sexual assault.
Vimeo.
Oh,
come on.
I feel like he's well protected against girls.
So privileged.
That's so crazy.
That's just.
Look at him.
He probably fucked her.
He's essentially got a face condom on right now.
Has a finger in her.
They got together,
did some odd couple sex
is so weird.
The things that people try to get away with like something like that,
like how could you try to get away with that,
how you don't know that that's a bad thing to do this,
this,
this.
Making someone go to court in arresting them for sexual assault,
for kissing a fucking woman who's gently kissing a policeman's outfit.
Children here.
This dude went into chase.
Reverend Billy,
well known prior to protest rate was facing a year in jail cause he went into
chase bank with some people and they sang about the death of the rain forest or
something and they called it riot.
Causing a riot or they should go to jail for being dumb,
but riots for a singing is a riot.
You can't save the rain forest at the fucking bank by singing so misguided.
Seriously.
That's like trying to win a game of pool when you're at home in bed.
To be fair in this picture that we don't know if this lasted for 30 minutes.
Her trying to grope them and like tried to grab his dick.
You know what I mean?
She says kissed.
If she did all that other stuff,
they would.
They would drag it out.
It would.
They would add that as well.
All she did kiss him.
She kissed him.
I mean his pants were off during that,
but people are so fucking silly like that.
Look,
you know what happened there?
No one got hurt.
Like the idea that you would do that,
try to take someone through the legal system for something so silly.
That makes me angry that you have any power because you're a petty piece of
shit.
You know,
to do that to someone to just kiss you.
Come on,
you're a pending piece of shit.
That's cute.
You don't think it's cute that a beautiful woman kiss your fucking shield
Shinara you do stop.
It's like when that Uc Davis,
UC Davis got pepper
sprayed,
all those kids and the world just went fucking bananas.
You know,
it's the same thing.
Like,
you know,
that's not right.
You know,
you can't just walk up to children.
Did you see?
Maybe you can look it up,
but he sued and got something like $30,000.
Yeah.
For,
for getting fired or whatever.
After doing that.
Well from the Internet response for a posttraumatic stress.
Oh yeah.
He said it depressed him.
Of course it did.
Jesus,
how much he did that get deserved all deserved.
What?
This Guy Franco met my car,
I guess as he says,
he's not prepared to brush off the incident as a peaceful gesture.
God put an idiot.
The Italian police is broken.
Baroque was down at,
uh,
occupy La.
I went down there for one day,
like what did it smell like?
What did it smell like?
Yeah,
it's not fun.
It was like a year ago,
but it wasn't.
They weren't,
it wasn't.
The occupation was part of the art walk or whatever,
and they were getting writers.
I showed up.
They were getting shot with rubber bullets for writing and chalk on the
sidewalks and these kids had.
Some of these kids have these big bloody welds from where do those rubber
bullets can fuck you up and take on an eye too if they hit you in the eye.
I know a girl last night.
Oh my God.
It's so crazy from a fucking what I got shot with one of the long time ago.
You get shot with rubber bullets.
Yeah.
They in Ohio state campus.
Every time they played Michigan,
like shit just went crazy.
I people would catch cars on fire.
They would bomb the whole entire campus with a lot with tear gas and stuff.
So even if you're in your house,
you would still have tear gas in your house and say that.
You mean the students would do that?
The cubs,
the campus police to break up the protest.
Well,
it wasn't.
It was just nonstop partying.
Like every street had houses on our cars on fire and party in here.
Some tear gas.
Yeah,
so they used to,
they used to just shoot the rubber bullets to get us off the streets and I was
just walking from a bar to my house trying to get back to my house.
They're like,
get in your house.
I'm like,
I'm trying to walk and they just start firing at as it hit me in the leg and my
whole leg just bubbled up and got black and it hurt.
Like fuck.
Yeah,
that's some rude shit.
I mean those fucking things.
It's not like like a nerf bullet,
the rubber and they're going like bullet speeds,
you know?
I think that's pretty fucking trains train guys used to shoot us,
try to shoot us to like,
like on train tracks.
We would always like put like nickels and quarters,
like on the train tracks and stuff and they would see us near and they'll just
start firing these guns and then they wouldn't really aim it at it.
They were just trying to scare us.
They were rubber bullet guns,
but they were just like firing in the air and they're fucking Ohio,
a bunch of savages and they might as well be in the dark ages.
That's a weird thing that people are doing this bullet bullet look that's next
to that kid.
That dude got jacked.
It is really weird.
They're allowed to do that.
I mean,
come on.
Especially when it's really drives me crazy is when they look at the size of
that,
the proof that they've used agent provocateur is to break up protests where they
hire cops to put masks on and start breaking shit.
Tons of them and then they go to the protest is a breaking shit.
We have to hire cops and arrest everybody and suddenly
they move in.
They turn a non peaceful protest into a or a peaceful protest and do a violence.
I mean that's the thing that most of these occupied like half of the people that
know,
like a quarter of the people were cops.
That's the inside joke,
right?
It got to the point where people were saying that there's like 30 something
percent like literally of all occupy people wonder if that guy,
the CIA guy was there to fake it was his job in climate experts trying to save
the world.
He's also trying to get some hippie pussy.
Yet
you tried to go to the
COUPA.
What is the current status of occupied because it seemed like it was real
exciting for awhile,
but now it just seems like it's been infiltrated like the mob
and brought to its knees.
I mean,
I think that,
I don't know whether the brand occupy will continue,
but the activists that were kind of activated by occupy,
I think they're all still out there and then I'll do it.
A lot of things.
A lot of it's online,
down.
I don't.
I'm not trying to demean their efforts,
but what I'm saying is that at one point in time there was this sense when all
these people were lining up around these businesses and they're camping out in
the,
in these parks.
There was a sense that like the way I described it was like it was almost like
some white blood cell cells had gathered around some sort of an injury,
like some white blood cells figured out there's something wrong with this area
and we're just going to surround it until we figured it out and that's what
these people are dealing with.
Standing there and having all their speeches and the parks and protesting and.
But then it became like a thing to do as well.
It became like,
you know,
it developed like sort of like a social thing of its own.
It became,
when you show him Brian,
this is like some of the Shit I was telling you,
oh look at Ohio state stuff.
The occupy thing became like I was listening to this interview with this kid who
is a,
he was in college and didn't know what he's going to do with his life and he
decided to drop out,
become a part of the occupy movement.
And like then once I saw that it became clear what I should do with my life.
And I'm like,
wow,
okay.
I don't know about that.
A lot of people rocky were activated by it and kind of realized what was going
on with our society and I think that's incredibly important.
I mean,
you also have to,
you know,
yes,
there are a million failings and we could go through them all,
but you have to think this is the first ever spontaneous global protest movement
in mankind's history.
That's an achievement in and of itself and it also changed the entire
conversation in the country from austerity to the fact that hey,
these like couple of thousand people have an incredible amount of wealth.
Yeah.
What I was going to say is that it was sort of one of those things when you've
seen all these people protest,
were you,
you were realizing that this,
this model of like no leader thing,
it doesn't really work.
Yeah.
No.
It needs to be something in between.
I believe that yeah.
It's like this.
It's sort of like got infiltrated and then sort of scattered and it lost its
message in a lot of people's eyes and then it stopped being relevant.
A lot of people,
when they talk about the news,
you don't really hear about occupy protests very often anymore.
It was a big thing for quite a while.
We'd hear about it on a regular basis,
but I think I,
I hate the idea of leaders,
but I think there's something to at least like a governing body that keeps
everything together.
Yeah.
There needs to be some leaders that I think there needs to be some democracy
stuff,
some form.
Um,
but it was interesting to see.
I mean,
a lot of their,
a lot of the collapse of it besides the pepper spray and the,
and the shooting with rubber bullets and all that stuff that was done.
Uh,
you know,
it was because the media all Kinda came together and said we are all going to
trash it.
I mean the New York Times first article on it like online or whatever,
a few days in or maybe a weekend was just saying how stupid it was and how,
oh,
the mascot of the movement is this topless girl who's dancing.
And it was like ridiculous.
I was down there.
I knew exactly what they were talking about it,
it was ridiculous.
And uh,
and so that's the left wing,
New York Times.
I mean,
that's,
that's our media,
the number.
When Giuliani was doing that speech,
he said,
why don't you go occupy a job?
Eh,
a bad opening act and Jersey maybe because a lot of these people were occupying
a job for like $7 an hour and couldn't afford the bus home from the job.
Yeah.
You want to talk about it?
Dude is out of the loop.
Are you really saying that man?
Yeah.
This billionaire.
Why don't you?
Yeah.
Where are you?
The mayor of fucking New York City.
Like hello?
You don't know that it's a mess out there.
Yeah.
Occupy a job.
Did you really fucking silly bitch.
It just seems that it's,
it's the sign of the Times that I'm enough people like get together and go.
Yeah.
Like if there's enough agreement that you can have this gigantic,
huge movement without a leader.
But I think ultimately that's one of the issues with it.
The non defined structure and non defined leadership position.
Yeah.
It can both be a,
it can both be a benefit and a detraction.
I mean,
look at like say for example,
Wiki leaks.
It was like they were able to collapse that thing by imprisoning essentially
Julian assange.
It's the guy at the top.
So you take one leader,
you can cut that head off real easy,
but if you had,
let's say,
a lot of leaders to some degree or a lot of,
uh,
you know,
each,
each different area elected somebody to kind of run things or whatever.
Did you see the salon piece on?
Um,
uh,
on there,
there were,
there's discussion about offering Edward Snowden,
amnesty who discussion by who there's certain NSA officials that are considering
amnesty for Stoughton and there
proposing because they're really nervous because apparently only one percent of
what he might have has been put out.
So there's a lot of stuff they're nervous about coming out.
So
State Department Justice Department aren't on board.
They don't want to do it.
They think it would encourage the,
uh,
future Edwards Rosa.
Yeah.
But man,
if they're,
if they're actually saying that though,
they,
they must be so terrified.
Terrified,
and in my opinion that there's a fucking hero.
He.
Well,
he's like,
he's a digital Paul revere.
I mean,
people should be furious.
Know that it's coming like,
hey,
look at what's being done in the enemy.
The enemy is spying on you all the time and listen whether you love Obama,
what do you hate?
Obama.
This is a dictator's toolkit.
Whether Obama's,
let's say Obama wasn't even using it.
This is a dictator's tool kit for the next dude that gets into office.
Yeah,
and it's the idea that we're supposed to just tolerate that because it's the
government.
Like there's a whole reason why there's a constitution.
There's a whole reason why people are elected into office,
right?
Because they're supposed to represent our state of government.
They're supposed to represent some really clearly thought out rules that were a
lot of the times designed to,
to,
to factor in the possibility of corruption.
So they kept out the influence of religion and they kept out the influence of
corruption.
There was this all done on purpose.
It was all like really astutely engineered
branches,
all that shit.
And slowly but surely elected officials just chipped away and all that stuff
just right in front of us,
chipped away and everyone was busy paying attention to Kim.
Kardashians asked and nobody even noticed that it was happening.
Slowly but surely things at the end day a good pass.
No,
no.
Indefinite detention.
Yeah.
American deaths in detention with not only that,
you don't have rights to an attorney,
you don't have.
It's craziness.
It's like Soviet Russia type shit.
This is shit.
It's like you can't do that.
This is America
on,
on my web series.
I interviewed,
uh,
Chris Hedges,
who was one of the people taken Obama to court over India.
And uh,
they,
they ultimately lost,
but they scared the shit out of the government that they couldn't use this thing
where they imprison people without a trial or charges.
It's insane.
It's so crazy that you would want to do that.
Why?
Why would you want to go around all of our checks and balances that are in place
to ensure that people that are being tried or actually guilty?
Why would you want to do that?
The only reason why you'd want to do that,
if you want to use that power to imprison people for your own whims,
for your own decisions because you,
you decided this guy's a,
uh,
an enemy of your,
your,
your cabinet,
whatever the fuck you decide when you want that guy.
Yeah.
Demonized.
And,
and,
and you know,
same idea with Americans.
He's got Americans on his kill list and Eric holder was asked,
hey,
what would you ever take out an American on American soil?
And his response was,
it would have to be a really bad thing going on.
Like,
you're like,
so you said yes,
you would take out an American on American soil.
Like it's insanity.
Well,
they were considering doing that.
Christopher dormer,
do you remember that?
Christopher dormer was the cop
killed,
killed a family of police officers,
killed police officers and killed a bunch of people.
And then there was talk in the news and a bunch different newspaper articles
that I read would that he might be the very first domestic use of the drone for
combat and they might.
Sure.
Imagine fucking death for the sky,
bitch,
take out the whole neighborhood again,
shoot a gang of cops in their family.
They're going to shoot missiles at you from the air.
We have A.
There's a big disparity between the capabilities of the average American
citizen,
the human being and the government that runs these average human beings,
and whenever you have an imbalance of power,
you're going to have abuse because people are going to want to have some of that
power.
They're gonna want to have a taste?
You got to keep them down in order to enjoy this position that you're in.
You've got to fucking make some.
Make some decisions and be tough on people.
And I'm looking at your email,
bitch,
how about that?
I'll,
I'll monitor every single one of your calls because I want to make sure you know
a terrorist.
Okay?
But meanwhile you're just Bob Smith who got elected to office and decided to
change the entire rules for running the government.
Like they're not like monks.
They're not like these guys who have meditated for 20 years on a mountain and
achieved enlightenment and then became the perfect leaders for our society,
but regular guys with stupid shoes,
with those slippery bottom shoes,
with tassels,
fucking Weirdos.
These guys,
the regular rich dudes that are abusing their power and people should be fucking
furious about this.
I don't understand why there's not
more outrage because we don't feel it.
That's a very good friend.
He's a very good friend.
He's a very nice guy.
He's a writer.
He's very smart,
and he said,
Oh,
you know what,
man?
I don't feel it.
I'm looking around at my friends.
They're doing good.
I'm looking at a lot of my family.
They're going good.
I go,
oh my God,
that is the car.
That's like saying that if you in a sunny field somewhere in Kansas,
you can't believe that Pakistan has a tornado.
Right?
This is one of the dumbest things I've ever heard and you can't imagine it might
come back to you eventually.
Yeah.
The idea that like you're doing good and your friends are doing good,
so there's not that much corruption,
like it's not like it's.
These are rumors like all this stuff is admitted it.
Everyone admitted it
and every time you know and people will stand up for certain things.
Every time they try and pass some gun legislation.
People get furious.
All right,
and I,
and I'm not talking about whether you should have guns or not,
but the people who stand up for that stuff should also stand up against this
other stuff because all those things you have your gun for to protect your
freedom,
your family,
a property,
they're taking that by other means there your freedom's gone.
The reading your emails,
you can be locked away without a trial or charges.
Your family's indebted to student loans and we'll end up at some job they hate
because they're paying that shit off the rest of their lives.
You know half your shift,
your houses foreclosed on,
all that shit you want to protect with a gun they'd taken without guns.
Why?
Fox News?
Chicks.
They're too.
They're too hot.
You want to just make them happy.
You want it.
You want to just tell them,
hey,
I'm a hunter.
I'm a fisherman.
Outdoorsman.
I mean,
I think everyone should be able to carry a concealed weapon.
This is America.
God Damn it.
Yeah.
We have obamacare.
Come on,
get on with it.
I mean,
what is even trying to prove with that?
No,
there's a reason.
Well,
we need to fill.
We need to fix our healthcare system,
but unfortunately the way he did it was by basically saying no,
the insurance companies could go nuts.
Yeah.
I think what happened is he wanted to do something.
I mean this is a total optimist.
Guess that he wanted to do something good and then the only way he was able to
pull it off at all was to make it some sort of a county shell game with the
insurance companies actually profit off of it,
but ultimately everybody does get some sort of healthcare.
I think healthcare,
I mean this is one thing that I fully believe in healthcare and police and like
cleaning the streets and disposing of waste and all that stuff should be taken
care of by any logical healthy society.
First,
education,
health,
safety,
cleanliness,
all that.
Primarily that's primary.
After that,
let's worry about Janet Jackson's nipple on television.
let's worry about all these other things like the idea that people should have
to pay for their own healthcare and like,
look man,
I've been at the point of being in a society.
Exactly.
We can use our money,
right?
Pay Doctors and the doctor should be paid well,
by the way,
the big problem with doctors in these situations is that the,
the doctors always get fucked.
They have massive malpractice insurance and huge student loans.
They have to pay off.
When I go to a doctor now they're afraid to say anything because they,
they think,
oh well,
it might come back to me.
So they say,
well,
it could be this thing.
It might not be in my.
I don't know.
You're like,
Hey,
I stubbed my toe,
do I have cancer?
And he was like,
probably not because they don't want to say you don't have cancer because then
if you have cancer,
they're fucked.
Yeah.
Then you'd sue them because.
Right.
About your cancer and Jesus Christ.
But I think that there should be a bunch of well motivated,
well paid doctors and teachers and policemen that should be taken care of right
away and they're going to change the idea of the role of a policeman and the
idea of the role of a teacher.
They should be noble position.
Right?
Right.
We shouldn't only give I,
you know,
we get perks in society to celebrities like tables at restaurants and things
like that.
I think like the best teachers in the country should be able to like,
you know,
have a fuck a 14 year old every once while not get in trouble.
Right.
Fourteen year old
boy and it's a girl.
It's Fox News checks.
That's a joke.
Yeah.
How dare you busted joke out about that.
Um,
do you think that there's.
What are you showing more?
Oh my God.
She's putting on a God damn show.
Well,
she's got it down to a science.
She knows exactly what that lends is.
She's Melfi.
She's very Melfi.
Yeah.
Those girls,
you get them alone to go crazy on you.
Um,
I forgot what I was going to talk about.
No,
I don't.
She scares me.
I'm lucky.
I'm happy.
Um,
did you see that video on my feet at this fucking idiot putting his arm in a
tiger's mouth is playing with a tiger.
Go back to,
uh,
go on my feet about nine hours ago on my twitter feed is the most ridiculous
thing ever.
I can't believe this guy was willing to do this and just hopes that this tiger
plays plays along with them.
It's so hard to watch the Tigers biting his arm.
Like it has this entire arm and its mouth and it's got these huge giant teeth.
See if he gets spread that out.
Where was he?
That he had a tiger?
I don't know.
I think he's a trainer,
but look at this crazy ass hole.
Oh my God.
This tiger is literally biting his whole arm.
It's so big.
That head is so big.
It would just snap his arm.
Right?
Uh,
anytime it wants to and he's just sticking it in there and look at the dog.
How about that dog that's circling the situation?
He's like,
what the fuck is that?
Did you see the dog?
That poor dog is like,
maybe he fills up the dog doesn't know what the fuck to do the dog.
He's like,
okay,
what the fuck is that?
The dog,
the tire gets filled up on dogs and then doesn't need the human and the dog
doesn't know what the fuck to do.
He's not going to protect you.
Did you see the guy that sleeps with a tiger?
And like dogs like this,
like this tiger is just like,
hey,
I'm just hanging out.
Yeah,
these people are assholes.
These people are assholes.
You know why?
Because they encourage other people to do this too.
And maybe you can pull it off.
Maybe you have this incredible rapport with tigers,
but this idea that we're supposed to do a lot of really dangerous shit with big,
wild,
dangerous animals is so fucking stupid.
You just shouldn't be surprised when that duty.
It's that guy.
Well,
we played a video last week of this train.
Bear attacking the trainers.
I think it was a train is one of the trainers,
relatives like his brother or something like that.
This bear just got to nowhere.
I just decided to rip his throat out there doing these,
these things there.
They're training them.
The guys just standing there.
The guy's not threatening the bear at all and the bear says,
you know what,
I'm just going to fuck this dude up real quick.
Just attached rips them apart.
Maybe it was when you tried to put them on the tricycle and he decided he'd had
enough.
Did you ever see that video where the bear eats the monkey?
No.
Oh my God.
It's a Russian circus bear.
Pull that shit out.
Brian Russian circus bear attacks monkey there.
There was a monkey driving a bike and the bear was driving a bike and they
collided the monkey foul and the bear ran over the monkey.
Yeah.
Atacheo kids watching at a circus and the bear just decided to fuck that monkey
up because the bear didn't know.
I thought it was being attacked by the monkey to do.
Not that smart.
They're in pain.
They fell.
They see the monkey,
the preacher.
That monkey caused this,
so they just bid bites the shit out of this monkey.
During Shakespeare's time,
one of the most popular shows was a monkey riding a horse and then a bear would
try and like eat the monkey or whatever it was called.
It was called bear baiting and Oh my God,
they fucking loved it.
I've heard of it.
Bear baiting and other ways.
I've heard a one bear baiting thing.
Would they take a pit bulls and they would tie the bear down by chains.
Then release the dogs on him and see how many dogs it took to take down a bear.
The bear is frustrated because he was losing to I think,
but I don't think there's a competitive,
like watch the monkey falls in the bear,
falls on the monkey,
and he's like bitch.
And just attacks him.
Oh,
so he was like using the bike to catch the monkey and eat him.
No,
no,
no.
The monkey fell when the bear ran over the monkey.
It's not the bay.
The bears,
not a strategy guy.
Thinking five steps ahead.
I kind of figured out how to fuck this monkey up and make it look like it's his
fault.
They just did.
A documentary is supposed to be good about that.
A killer whale that ate the trainer.
Oh,
the about blackfish?
Yeah,
no doubt.
Yeah.
We
had one of the guys in from marine land that was originally want to till it
comes trainers.
Oh really?
Yeah.
We had him in a couple of weeks ago,
Phil Dimmers,
and he was fascinating.
He was telling us like,
how it's just a goddamn business.
Like they don't give a fuck about those.
They treat him like shit.
Those animals were really smart.
Wow.
This pan is fucking this dude up
dude.
I've never seen a panda that excited about anything.
Yeah,
you would think a panda wouldn't really give a fuck about you.
Once that jacket,
he was wearing Jean jacket on genes.
Genes.
It turns out Jay Leno look,
he's like,
I hate prison.
Turns out a panda is a bear at the end of the day,
he's like,
I hate prison.
Come on,
why you got me in prison?
You fucks.
But I'm.
Phil was talking to us about marine land,
about how depressing it has seen those,
those workers trapped in these fish tanks and they want to have sex with their
kids because it just confused and they're isolated and it's really,
really evil.
If you haven't seen blackfish,
go see it and if you haven't seen the podcast with Phil was very enlightening
and eyeopening and if you go to save smooshy.com,
you can actually aid in his legal defense because he's getting sued by the
people of marine land who really cancel seaworld Gig.
Yeah.
Martina mcbride is one of them.
Willie Nelson.
Joan Jett canceled.
Yeah.
These are just the latest ones.
Everybody has canceled.
They.
They should boycott those things.
Those things are prisons.
Those are prisons for aliens.
The aliens that live under the water and they're smart as shit.
And if we found them on another planet and we will worship them.
Right?
Right.
But because they're in the ocean and because we can catch them with these big
nets and scooping up with cranes,
we do it.
We're assholes.
People who run seaworld,
you are fucking assholes.
No one knows those dolphins and whales more than you guys do.
And you know what you're doing.
So fuck you.
I've never gone to sea world.
I never will go to see what I've always thought.
Cal was fucked up and talking to this guy just.
He just cemented that thought in my mind.
It's just,
it's not because they grab them as kids.
I mean the part,
the part.
I only saw two minutes of the documentary,
but they grabbed the kids out of the water and the rest of the whales wait
around because they don't want to leave because they realize one of them has
been trapped and it's so fucked,
dude.
They're smart,
man.
It's,
it's,
we can't do that.
That's not cool.
You can't do that just because you can't understand what they're saying when
they complain.
We know they're smart.
You know?
It's one of the most evil things.
I mean,
it's essentially slavery.
It's no different than slavery and the idea that it is like this is not a
goldfish.
Okay.
You can take a gold fish and do whatever you want to it.
I don't give a shit.
You could eat a goldfish for a prank.
You will never hear me complain.
You know why?
Because goldfish aren't smart.
I like smart things and things that are really smart.
Know not like dogs,
pigs,
smart.
Like dolphins are really fucking smart.
Like kind of people smart in some weird way.
And you,
you're an asshole if you put that in the fucking swimming pool.
They like use tools.
Yeah.
Well they're.
They're maniacs and they do a lot of bad things and there's a video of a master
of masturbating.
Dolphin was fucking a headless fish.
They're crazy.
They're hypersexual is side.
There's a lot of humans.
You got your genius is and then you've got the ones that are seeing how big the
asshole.
No doubt and much like humans,
the vast majority of them are good.
You know,
if you're walking around on the street in any normal city,
the vast majority of the people that you run into are good people and not trying
to be criminals.
They're not trying to hurt others or just most people are good people.
It's just the ones that are not good stand out to me.
Focus on them and it becomes something that people want to pay attention.
I have a,
I have a thing I do in my act about how these top billionaires like the Koch
brothers and shit like we,
I hate when people go to them for advice on like how to run the society.
Like they're,
they're psychopaths.
I mean there you wouldn't respect anyone else who collects a billion of
something or like,
you know,
if you find that someone's got a million shoes,
they have a fucking problem.
What about if a guy like Bill Gates,
I think I've read everything I've heard.
He's kind of a psychopath to not the not the initial inventing stuff.
It's the,
it's what you do after that.
Right?
Well,
what is it?
Is it just that he kept going and kept making more and more and more to the
point where he just,
who needs $90,000,000,
dude?
Well,
it's not just make it,
it's,
I mean the way they make more.
I don't know specifically about what Microsoft does,
but it's a lot of like,
you know,
tearing apart anybody else that could threaten them and does apple,
apple is pretty ruthless.
I'm not defending any.
It comes to competition.
All these businesses where they're making tons of money,
you know,
they protect that shit.
It's a game.
It's just like protecting your pieces.
If you're playing chess,
if you're in the business to make money,
that's,
you know,
you offer good products.
So your conscience is clear.
I mean apple makes a hell of a laptop,
they make great stuff,
but
I don't know if they're conscious,
if they're kind of looking at the netting around the Foxconn factory in us.
Essentially no one
can be.
No one can be conscience clear because we all get these conflict minerals that
power electronics and they almost all come from impoverished areas with a lot
of,
for the longest time that Congo is of slaves that were doing it.
Still still is in a lot of places.
I mean,
vice did some powerful work on that.
Uh,
Shane Smith,
it will be here on Wednesday.
They,
um,
they went there and they investigated the whole what's,
what's going on,
like why do we need to be here?
Like what,
what is,
what's the main appeal?
And it's cold hands cold Tanja.
It's stuff that they used to make cell phones.
We need it all cell phones.
So it's almost impossible to like have a conflict free like electric car.
But here's the thing,
you could pay,
I mean a different.
If our system was set up differently,
you could pay those workers mining that Colton a nice wage,
a livable wage.
No Shit.
There was a um,
there's,
there's some,
I don't know if they ever got done,
but I know it was,
it was a proposition to make cell phones that were,
there's a thing called free phone and everything,
but I think they only went when they only had like three g they didn't have like
for lte that we're like a step behind
where people are like,
oh,
I need the latest shit.
I want to,
I want to save the world.
But the cell phone that I had last year,
it's not good enough.
Listen,
I need some new shoes.
I need to save the world.
But this cell phones a month old.
So at htc one,
can you do that?
Can you make me one of those people don't want the older shit.
We've,
we've been carefully trained to not want the eldership.
Is that what it is?
We've been trained,
isn't it though?
Isn't it just a natural human inclination to always want the best?
Yeah.
So I think it's a natural human inclination.
Like I,
I feel that materialism.
I think materialism is obviously an empty pursuit.
I mean,
I don't think anybody can argue that the pursuit of objects ultimately over
everything over emotions and friendships and love affairs does stupid,
stupid objects are not going to make you happy.
You need all those other things,
but if you have all those other things,
then objects are pretty cool.
You know?
I mean if,
if somebody gives you like a really dope lamp and you put it in your office,
you're like,
this thing is fucking bad ass and you look at it,
it gives you like a good feeling.
That's a bacterial thing that you own.
That's actually pretty nice and artworks falls into that as well.
I mean,
our work essentially is materialism.
If you're collecting paintings,
I mean you're,
you're collecting someone's expression and someone's work,
but you're also collecting a material thing,
right?
You're collecting an object,
but I think.
I think it's a vicious cycle in which we're,
we're told to always want the newest one and they are.
The companies were rewarded for designing something that changes every month.
I mean,
I boot it up.
I hadn't used my ipad and I just didn't have any use for it for like two years
and I rebooted it up.
Nothing works with it anymore.
You can't know apps work nothing because it's designed to kick you off and say,
Oh,
you gotta get a new one,
or what are you going to,
you know,
everything stops working well.
There's a reason for that though.
The reason for that engineering wise is that they want to be able to control
their product ultimately and they want to make it the best experience possible.
Like there's A.
There's not a logical,
but there's a technological reason for some of the only updating the operating
system.
Constantly updating the applications constantly.
They improve them,
they get them out of time,
but changing the shape of the changing the shape of the plug.
Oh well you can't have the old plug,
but it transfers data quicker and it was that they had the old books in the new
plugs a million times if you will.
Right,
and you're wrong at the same time.
You're right.
If you want to think as far as economics and like,
yeah,
you should be able to save people money,
let him use a USB plug.
Why do you have to have this thing that nobody else has?
But the thing that nobody else has works better,
which is it's a better.
It transfers data quicker.
It's a better connection.
Allegedly.
What do I know?
If you have,
if you have like a playstation one goal,
you're not going to play it like a playstation four shit called five.
What is the new thing?
Lightening Bolt connection.
Is that what it is?
Is that.
And is that what connects your,
um,
like a iphone five?
Yeah,
lightening bolt connector better.
Okay.
Here's the question.
Oh yeah,
it's a lot better.
It's a lot faster and it's a different USB.
Also.
The old one is
a lot slower.
The connections.
Remember like,
uh,
where uh,
you would always have problems with like plugs,
like,
or if he had like a alarm clock that had a doc system in it always had that
wiggle thing where you had to put something behind it just to get it connected.
That's because it was just not a well designed plug for multiple years.
Yeah,
apparently it does.
It does.
It transfers data,
quicker transfers.
Wow.
Data up to 10 gigabytes per second.
Double the speed of current USB three point zero.
So that just answered it.
We're only talking about tech.
I mean there's,
there's other things.
Shelves shelves collapsed and a month now I get like Ikea Shit.
Yeah.
But we're talking about updating applications and how your ipad wouldn't work
and I really think that that's because they're just constantly upgrading shit
and then making it better and faster and I agree.
It's frustrating if you're trying to save money,
but if you're not trying to save money,
that's what you want them to do.
You know,
you want everybody to push the latest shit,
you know,
like Oh,
so what?
I have to get a new plug,
but now my business can transfer its data in 20 minutes as opposed to 40 minutes
or so.
I've got the older phone,
whatever this says the android and I've had it for like two years and I still
works fine.
I just don't have the fastest phone.
He's telling my dad,
what's going on with you?
You're a young man.
You're young,
you're healthy.
I don't need the fastest phone
works fine.
It works,
but I used to joke about that.
I use a carrier pigeon.
I you do a joke about 12 years.
No one ever looks at cell phones.
It goes,
okay,
that's it.
We're done.
Screen's big enough.
Fast enough.
It's not gonna happen like we,
for whatever reason,
we need the latest,
greatest shit.
We all do.
And you might not because you're a fucking loser.
Bohemian.
Which a two year old ipad.
I'll pull out my etch a sketch.
It's,
it was good for a laugh
glances.
Yeah.
I think.
I honestly think that what we're talking about,
materialism,
although it's kind of an empty pursuit,
I really think that it's one of the things that's pushing,
um,
what human beings are doing on this planet overall,
which is advancing technology.
I think one of the things that we do,
if you looked at us just completely outside of our culture,
outside of your life,
outside of your,
your you know,
your reality and looked at this swarm of beings and what's at the forefront of
swarm of beings.
It's objects.
They're constantly creating newer cars,
bigger tvs,
better computers,
better phones,
constantly obsessing objects,
and they're working jobs they don't even enjoy just to feed the machine that
creates these objects,
which is a really sad.
When you get a job they don't enjoy.
I don't know if it's.
There's a lot of people though.
That's my point.
A good percentage of people made a mistake somewhere and did something that they
don't want to do.
Good percentage that did it for just a living and there's no passion to their
life.
It's a good percentage.
I wonder though if when you see all this symbiotic connection that we have,
like with cell phones,
like you can't leave your house about yourself when you feel weird.
You know,
you're talking about the google glass.
We're going to have to be aware that we're becoming more and more addicted to
all these closer and closer and closer to it to.
It might be the whole reason for materialism in the first place.
It might be.
That's the pole of materialism.
Materialism might ultimately be the engine that creates a symbiotic relationship
between pizza.
Very positive way to look at them.
I don't even think it's positive because it sounds pretty negative,
you know,
this wouldn't be a lot of shit that's different.
I do agree.
I mean technology is increasing exponentially and in some ways it's great and in
some ways like I feel like we could be using it for better things and when like
the,
the drone Amazon delivery system that they've been talking about like alright,
it's lovely you're bringing a slap chop to an agoraphobic obese coleslaw addict.
But you know,
couldn't those drones be used for something more important?
Well for them,
I mean their,
their business is selling people shit,
so why would they do that?
Right.
There's obviously other drones,
but if they're going to use that drone for their business,
at least it's cool.
At least you know you're hanging out in the city and see drones fly by dropping
off packages.
That's some more wealthy and shit though,
man.
Yeah.
I don't trust those people.
They're going to break.
I get nervous about a Roomba.
Don't know.
I don't know.
He's reporting back to when is one of I'm going to run out of batteries and
spiral run into some little kid's stroller.
Oh yeah.
The first week it's going to happen.
You can't tell me those things or feel proof and how about people shooting
amount of sky.
You're going to get some crazy rednecks like Colorado.
They passed a law in some area.
Colorado allowing you to shoot drones.
Yeah.
They can't do it,
but they can try.
You get it all out.
Well,
if you have a high speed rifle and it's hovering,
if you catch it hovering and you have a shitty Ras guy,
people to tell them at the Amazon drone.
It's not the full sized drones.
They're talking about drones period.
This state,
Colorado loud.
I just didn't know if it was possible for the type of yeah,
you can do it.
It's been done.
They've done it with rocket launchers,
they've done it with like heat seeking missiles.
I know they've taken drones out before.
Definitely.
And if you have a high powered rifle with a scope and it hovers.
If it's not like moving again,
if ain't even.
If it is moving,
you can lead it,
you know,
if you're a really good sniper,
like one of those marines,
a lot of the time they're supposed to be a mile up where you can't see them.
Oh,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
If they're mild,
well I guess they can be right.
I mean they could be as high up as they want to know people in there.
They're often like,
when they're bombing over in Afghanistan,
you can't see them so crazy.
It's such a weird thing that we just accepted that as part of our.
Our civilization.
Yeah.
How far we've come over the past 50 used to be like 10 years ago.
If someone was like,
dude,
this drones taking people that you'd be like,
well,
what are you smoking?
And they don't even try to make it seem like it's just,
at least the Patriot Act was called.
The Patriot Act,
you know what I mean,
like this is they've given up on the Wellington Hellfire missiles.
Hell fire.
What does it say up there,
Brian?
What did the uh,
the headline say,
alright it's town vote on drone ordinance postpone.
Oh,
someone got a hold of them.
But yeah,
they were gonna.
They were gonna make it so it'd be who shoot drones.
Oh,
we're so crazy.
I'm never going to happen because there's bullets are going to fall down and hit
people and shit like that.
Well that happens every year on New Year's and these assholes go shooting off
their guns.
Bullets land on people.
Yeah.
People die every year of that somewhere in the country.
So when the world sounds awesome,
there's something beautiful about that terrible.
One hundred 50 people die every year because coconuts falling there.
Yeah.
Know far more people die from peanut allergies in this country than terrorism.
Isn't that crazy?
Peanuts or a motherfucker.
That's my argument against.
We'd like when Dr drew type characters start talking about like the the
withdrawal symptoms of we like a not so much,
not for like normal people for one of the peanut allergy freaks.
Yeah,
it will.
And it's the weeds not kill as many people as peanuts.
It's not killing anybody,
but I mean even the people that get these withdrawal syndromes like peanuts or
worse,
like peanuts,
peanuts are a higher percentage of people like the amount of people that are
getting like really addicted to weed.
Oh my God isn't even one in a thousand.
What are the symptoms like?
Boredom.
Just bored.
Well,
they say that they can't.
They have to have it.
They can't.
I think they're idiots.
I really do.
I think a lot of them that talk about being addicted to weed,
they're idiots.
I buy the ones that say if they do weeds and they'll start doing coke and then
they get crazy because it doesn't that start earlier,
like alcohol,
like do you have to put it on weed?
Is the gateway will also.
It's like why do you have to put it on anything?
Because what you're really doing is taking something that's innocuous and you're
just doing your natural escalating whether you would,
you would do with masturbating,
with gambling,
with prostitution.
You're a fucking crazy person,
right?
You know,
you're just looking to get nutty,
nutty.
And then you blame the weed.
Then Dr drew's got you on the couch and it's like,
when did you know that you were out of control?
The we'd pulled me.
It was a grip I,
I needed,
I couldn't get up without a bond yet,
like the girl's an idiot.
But the first time I fucked I was like,
this is really exciting and I want to do this more.
Yeah,
it can be that.
And I did a weed and then moved on.
Yeah,
I think,
uh,
it's,
it's like we were talking about earlier with the whole Fox thing.
It's like there's teams and the teams don't recognize that it's not an either or
thing is a lot of weirdness.
This life,
this life is weird as shit.
And you're telling me that marijuana should be illegal,
but you,
you're okay with people selling oxycontin's yeah.
Oh Dude,
you're okay with vicodins.
So much worse stuff is legal with Ambien.
Ambien is crazy like you're going to get addicted to something that you need to
sleep,
and if you don't take it,
you can't sleep and you'll go crazy.
Oh,
and by the way,
you might wake up while you're on it and do stuff on our governments.
Find with cigarettes to kill half a million people a year,
but their problem with medicinal marijuana or whatever,
like it's because that's the ultimate one,
right?
Cigarettes are the ultimate one.
It's the ultimate thing that you never hear a politician talk about when find me
one guy running for president ever that has said he wants to take cigarettes out
of the American people's hands.
Has anyone ever done that?
You actually have terrorist killed.
Half a million people a year will be so bummed out.
People would lose their shit if you volunteered for the terrorist organizations
and it killed them.
You get roped into it.
They didn't even know they got scared.
I got hypnotized and then addicted and they get brought into terrorist
organization than they murdered him.
Wow.
That's so sad.
We have to stop this.
Take out the word terrorist,
putting the word cigarette and that's what you have.
They hypnotize you with people looking cool,
you know,
and then you see cool people that are artists,
man or smoking man.
It's amazing.
The next thing you know you're trying it.
Next thing you know you're caught in some chemical web.
We're your actual cells.
Your tick did don don for real.
You see people that need it and they just fucking leave
dude.
Like life's a bitch.
And people got to medicate themselves against difficult illness called life in
various ways.
Yeah.
And I think that the idea that anybody's going to be able to tell you what you
could do is stupid.
Some people should take care of one.
I know that's not a popular thing to say should,
but I know some people have done some amazing music with heroin and uh,
I'm not saying that they should,
they absolutely had to do heroin to do that music,
but they did.
And the music is awesome.
So it is what it is,
you know,
it's not for everybody.
Yeah.
You're dumb to do heroin.
That's crazy.
It kills you.
But no liquid fucking.
We'll look at Devonna did Kurt cobain did,
one was on heroin and then we use all these drugs as an excuse to in prison
fucking half the country.
We have five percent of the world's population.
Twenty five percent of the world's prisoners.
Well,
that's the other thing that privatized,
privatized private prisons.
And then a prison guard unions that lobby to make sure that drugs are illegal
and you're like,
wait a minute,
why?
It's like they lobby,
make sure make sense.
Harsher,
harsher sentences.
They lobbied to make sure that we have work.
That's what they want to make sure that they want to make sure that we're out
there arresting people.
So we have works,
we have plenty of people to keep.
And,
and,
and the,
and the people making money from the privatized prisons that are lobbying for
that to fuck.
It's all our wellbeing.
I mean,
you add that to the fucking robots in the sky and the wars over oil.
it's some pretty incredible stuff that's going on right now.
Crazy shit.
You know,
freedom.
All this freedom talk.
Meanwhile,
the NSA's just looking at all your Dick Pics,
look at it every email he ever sent,
ever.
I want my guns,
but I don't.
I don't care if they're fucking looking at my dick pics.
I wonder what the fuck is going to happen with this snowden thing.
They say that he also has some sort of a
like a stash of really super crazy shit that he will release if anything ever
happens to him.
And they,
uh,
they have like a code for it.
Like JFK is the code.
You have to break into it.
You have to break like you have to,
you have to crack it.
In the hearings in the UK,
they said they've only released one percent of what he is.
That's the same.
How's that possible?
It's crazy.
How is that possible?
I don't know how much more crazy shit is.
Imagine if we found out that we're not even real.
They got on a disk somewhere.
We in the Matrix in the matrix plugged in,
make sure it's 100 percent.
Did you see that
new stuff about the simulation?
About the Hologram that was on?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's,
uh,
I'll pull that up.
It's bizarre.
The problem with this,
uh,
the latest evidence that the universe is a hologram.
The problem with all this stuff,
is that a headline?
I don't understand it.
No,
I couldn't understand it.
I can understand that.
I've tried to string theory stuff and this is this the cover of the slate
science page.
Do we live in a 10 dimensional hologram?
Okay.
I'm just going to shut this off.
Freaking me out the university and seeing bewildering and times in the past
century,
we've learned an incredible amount about the cosmos.
Thirteen point 8 billion year history.
It's structure including the number and distribution of galaxies in which is
really amazing.
When you stop and think they figured that out.
There's more gas in the galaxy.
No more stars than grains of sand on the beaches of the world.
Jesus crossed.
Not only that,
there's a very distinct possibility that the universe is fractal and infinite.
One of their ideas is that inside every galaxy is a black hole,
and inside that black holes and other universe,
I'm not high enough for this conversation.
It's not high enough.
It's not possible you can't get high enough because you do,
you just start talking,
start talking nonsense,
but it's a,
it's a really incredible thing that they've done,
like trying to study the smallest possible measured components of nature is that
as they've gotten deeper and deeper with this,
they've shown that the world is kind of magic.
It's,
it doesn't,
it's not based on any of the laws of reality that we observe in everyday life.
Like things aren't solid.
They're almost all air.
Yeah.
You're not actually touching anything.
Touch it.
It's,
it's the,
uh,
the vibration,
the forest,
the charge against is pushing the electric forest or whatever is.
Yeah,
we're going to butcher it,
but it definitely hardcore go google that from people who know what they're
doing.
Not Comedians,
but like when they talk about quantum theory and they would talk about article
particles in superposition where they're moving and then still at the same time.
Oh yeah.
And some of these particles that are only there,
they're only there when you observe them,
observe them,
they're not there.
And that's sort of the,
those are the beginning steps to this study of the possibility of the universe
is a Hologram and also simulation theory,
the possibility that what we are in right now is some indiscernible artificial
reality that we've created in the future and that we don't realize it because
it's so good,
it's just,
it's perfect.
But we got far enough to create something which we inevitably will.
That's indiscernible from regular reality and that's why it seems like some
piece of fiction,
you know,
that's why,
Anthony Wiener showing pictures of his Dick,
like really obvious shit.
He thinks get weirder and weirder,
you know,
and when these things,
these weird things happen over and over and over again,
it's almost like they're letting you know,
like this is just,
this is a,
this is a parody.
We created this,
this current present from the future.
Yeah,
it's pretty shitty.
Perfect.
I mean,
genital warts,
come on,
maybe.
No,
but maybe yes,
because I think there's a yin and a Yang to everything.
And if you could just all fuck everybody willy nilly would no rubber on and not
worry about it,
then it wouldn't be so pleasurable.
If you could fuck someone who didn't have herpes or just that's the zen idea
because experience some pain,
then you've presented it when it's not there.
Well,
I think there's a Yin and the Yang to the world just like everything else in the
universe.
I think there's a reason why we have evil and it's so that we can appreciate.
Good.
You know,
I think there is a reason why we have bad relationships.
We can appreciate good relationships.
I really believed that sounds ridiculous,
but I think they only people that ever learned are people that experienced both
highs and lows,
which is why lottery winners are almost always fucked.
Which is why people who are born rich are almost always you.
Have you seen the charts were people that become paraplegic and people that win
the lottery,
their happiness goes back to almost exactly after a year.
It goes back to almost exactly where they were.
Wow.
It's like you don't retain that.
That immense joy or immense sadness tends to come back to the mean.
It makes sense.
We're,
we're adaptable.
I mean,
we'd like to think that we are what we are right now,
but you know,
we are what we are right now is what we are because of the circumstances we
exist in.
If our circumstances existed,
like we were in the Congo,
digging Colton out of the mountain with a stick.
That's a reality.
You know,
you look at,
like a friend of mine wrote a book about Montezuma.
I'm Graham Hancock.
What wrote a book about a mile that zoom on the,
the,
uh,
the incredible shit the aztecs did,
like really it was a novel and we were,
we were talking about like living in that time,
like,
what am,
I would've been like to live in this crazy barbaric time of human sacrifice.
And that's all they knew.
That's all they knew.
Just like this is all we know is they're going to say the same thing about us
and about 10 years.
What was it like to live in that barbaric time?
Fox News?
What the fuck was going on there?
People were watching vaginas on the news while drone bombs were killing
grandmothers see women to actually think that.
We're just joking around about that.
Like that's not really a big deal to show your vagina without intelligence.
Not Rude,
but it really does sway men's opinion.
Totally fucking really,
really,
really done beyond that.
It's,
it's,
it's the weirdest thing ever.
Like if you see a girl and even if you have no shot at or whatsoever,
you even if you don't want to have sex with her,
you want her to like you.
If she's super hot and she's wearing some revealing crazy fox news type girl
clothing,
it's hypnosis.
It's not fair for straight men.
It's not fair.
Especially for dme.
Straight man,
and that's why so many dumb people like Fox News,
those,
those fuckers sirens.
They pull you into the rocks.
Yeah,
exactly.
Sirens into the rocks.
I like that fucking.
I always think it's weird.
I think we've talked about this before,
that that Fox News,
it's so cool with certain things like family guy,
like the cartoon Fox News,
but the company doesn't match the rest of the network because it's all Brian.
It's all about making money
and the Fox News with a way to make money in the news is the really obsessed
people,
conservative people,
the people that are like really into it and listening to like conservative talk
radio,
conservative talk radio dominates liberal talk radio.
I mean I don't know what the real numbers were,
but I knew back in the day,
but when Air America came on,
the idea behind Air America was that we needed a some sort of rebuttal to all
the right wing,
right wing talk,
rush limbaugh and Michael Savage type dudes that were everywhere.
And every time you turn on the radio you'd have angry white guys screaming about
immigration and all this crazy nonsense.
You know?
And I think that there's,
there's,
that's undeniable.
You know,
people are,
we,
we're not looking at it for what it really is.
Well,
so you look at where talk radio's biggest,
it's the middle of the country that's all red and they're out on farms and they
got nothing to do.
Listen to talk radio.
Yeah.
And you know,
they're also easily led and if you're really dumb,
you know,
if you're feel fearful and that stuff plays towards fear,
all that right wing stuff,
whether it's limb by or Michael Savage,
they're all fearmonger playing towards fear and that's how they make their
money.
So Fox News is just,
that's a great bankable market.
And then on top of that,
if you,
you know,
you're a guy like Rupert Murdoch who's like super conservative in the first
place.
You want to be able to influence culture.
You have to influence culture with the family guy.
It's not going to matter whether or not your television shows that are just
strictly entertainment based,
are conservative or liberal.
That doesn't matter.
Right?
But what really does matter is these fucking new shows,
the TV shows,
it's just about making some money.
What's the best way to make money?
Have people dance with stars.
I mean,
it's also about rapid
tish and the fact that they,
you know,
if the news says this thing over and over and over again,
that's what has the effect on family guy says one sentence that's not.
Yeah,
just becomes.
So yeah,
they can,
they can do incredible things by just repeating things in the news over and over
again.
And then people say,
I thought that this was going on.
You know,
that's God damn.
But if you just listen to certain news shows,
you're going to get that slant.
If you listen to MSNBC,
you gonna get that left wing slant.
If you listen to CNN,
it used to be a left wing side.
Well,
it's,
you know,
with Msnbc it's interesting because it is a,
a kind of left with sand,
but it's also very much Obama apologist.
And so if your more left than Obama like I am,
then you're like,
fucking give him a pass on everything.
It's like,
you know,
NSA surveillance is not okay just because it's Obama in office.
I wonder what it is,
man.
I wonder if it's the bill Hicks choke where you know,
you get into office,
they a smoky room filled with industrialists
and they show you a footage of the JFK assassination from an ankle.
No one's ever seen any,
any questions?
Just want to know what my agenda is.
I wonder what happens when you get in there because I've heard it.
Well,
here's,
here's what I would say about it is you don't get to the point that you could
get in there unless you've been approved by the business community.
I,
Rick Rubin was
behind Obama as a senator maybe even before.
Uh,
I mean,
as for the beastie boys.
So the guy
with the beard as he was,
he was behind Obama,
uh,
even as a state senator.
So basically deep in this politics thing,
you say names like Rick Rubin that gets you Brownie points though if you're at a
party.
Um,
but he,
you know,
so the.
Okay was already given for Obama as like,
he's with Wall Street's,
that kind of thing.
And whereas you see the people that don't get that,
okay,
look at Jill Stein or,
or even,
you know,
Ron Paul had when he was up for the caucus,
they're changing numbers and shit and uh,
you know,
Jill Stein was tried to attend the presidential debate and was arrested and
locked in a room,
chained to a charity,
the entirety of the debate in New York and then released after it was over.
Why?
What was the reason they said it was trespassing because he showed up to the
debates without a ticket and she even.
She said she's be like four foot five.
She was like a 60 year old woman.
And she said to the armed guard,
how about you two unchanged from the chairs?
We're not going to leave the room.
And he said,
no.
Oh my God,
that's our democracy.
This is the third.
This is the Green Party presidential candidate.
What was also really interesting watching people scramble when Ron Paul was
doing debates and watching the way the pundits on TV,
which is dismissive openly.
And they were.
There was one time where I believe Ron Paul was like in third place and someone
else's in fourth place and they were concentrating on the fourth place person
and they like ignored the fact that we're on the list was on the screen and they
said one,
two and four.
It's like,
what the fuck man,
it's so transparent and then he's got a son now and people are wondering if his
son is,
I'm going to play ball.
What's going to happen with Rand Razia chip off the old block.
It's all so weird,
man.
I think that ultimately though with the trends that are happening right now,
it's like a alternative news sources on the Internet and people getting to these
places,
the vice type people that are showing you what was really going on.
This is really where your cell phones come from.
This is really what kind of a political uprising is happening in Bahrain.
This is really what's happening in Syria.
This is the reason why the administration tried to get you to think that we need
to take military action and this is the reason why they ultimately back down.
Like the more that stuff comes out,
it's going to be so hard to fuck around.
Yeah.
It's going to be harder and harder to control it.
It's going to be so hard to control.
They're not going to be able to know and it terrifies the fuck out of them,
which is why they're trying to control the Internet more.
You know,
they tried to pass those bills that would kind of shut down the,
you know,
make the Internet less free and they failed a,
it was called Sopa and Pipa where the bills in Congress and people flipped out
and remember like a Google did a thing on it and everything and a day.
So it means it's because information is getting out there and it scares the shit
out of them and they're trying to make the internet chained down.
Meanwhile,
Google just bought Boston dynamics.
Did you see that?
Scariest shit ever.
Google is skynet.
They just bought this crazy robot company.
Yeah,
they keep buying crazy shit.
What else did they buy recently?
What was the other nutty thing to google bought or they bought.
They bought ways,
which is pretty awesome.
What's that?
That's a program that's using like a gps that tells you,
you know,
real time traffic because what it's doing is it's sending out how slow you're
going.
So people know like,
oh,
that's streets only going 30 miles per hour.
But you're getting the most accurate gps ever.
So pretty much google buy something that will be able to track you what's
already dragging.
Yeah,
fact.
I mean anytime anybody's got some sort of a thing when they're running from the
cops and they have a phone on,
they know exactly what you are.
Yeah.
But now it won't even have to be the phone on the car.
We'll be sending out the signal for sure.
I mean I think they already are.
I think,
you know,
when you have like that,
those uh,
what is that shit called?
Where a uh,
um,
what is it when a GM car,
when you press a button?
Onstar.
I have that in my new car and it scares me.
They find,
you know,
you get in a car accident on star goes,
we're sending a police,
right?
You know,
I don't,
I don't ever view myself as the type of guy that will need to go run and hide in
a barn somewhere,
but I would like to have that on the possibility on the table as like I could go
hide somewhere and you can't anymore,
but one day when no one can hide,
including bad people will be forced to reconcile what will be forced to alter
our opinion or alter our behavior rather to a more evolved state because
everyone's accountable for their own behavior.
Well,
the problem is the.
I think the largest bad people in terms of a structural society sense are not
considered bad people.
I mean the fucking heads of the government and the corporate assholes,
but don't you think they're considered bad people more now than they ever were
before?
Just what we're talking about,
the impact of Operational Wall Street or the occupy Wall Street movement is that
one of the things it's done is start the conversation,
be open up the dialogue about the discrepancy of income discrepancy of wealth in
this country and make it a topic of discussion in a way that's never really been
fully explored before.
It was just everybody knew they were rich people and poor people,
but now it's kind of quantified.
Six areas of the Walmart.
Fortunate,
the same amount of wealth as the bottom.
Forty percent of America,
$125 million.
They have friends.
Check this out recently.
Google by a computer vision robot arms.
These are companies and what they specialize in.
Robot arm robots,
robot wheels,
robotic cameras and then robotics,
but the the like the last mergers that they bought like the last eight or most
of them are robot based.
Isn't it ironic that their motto when they started was don't be evil?
Yeah.
Look at Google's new robot.
Watch a Time magazine from December 16th says,
watch Google's new robot run like hell,
this is fucking crazy.
It is a cheetah.
I mean it literally looks like a Cheetah.
Wait till you see.
What does it plan to do with that thing?
Oh,
that's a good question.
But where do you see the,
uh,
the thing run?
It's insane.
They have one version of it that I don't think is real at the beginning of it
where it shows it.
Pull it.
She,
it.
Just look for that.
Yeah.
But go,
go to the very beginning of it.
Go to the very beginning of before you click the link and you can see the,
uh,
the idea of the Cheetah,
the actual robotic Cheetah.
There's an image when the thing first starts.
Dude,
if that thing before you press play,
it's that thing wants to hump your leg if fucked.
Yeah.
Look at this.
Prior to that.
Yes.
Look at that.
What the fuck?
It's like a dead mouse.
Back at Dab a little so you can actually see the full image.
That's insane.
It's a robot fucking cat.
I don't know if that's real though.
That looks like a,
like an artist's rendering or something because actually it's a metal sheet
ahead.
But when you watch this thing run,
they can get sued fast.
Like a person,
like a really good sprinter.
I think they max out and like the thirties or forties,
like 30 miles an hour.
It's like,
you know,
maybe maybe the fastest guys in the world can get into the forties,
but these fucking things,
these things could run like cars.
What are they going to do with?
They're going to chase bad people.
They're going to make sure that the streets are safe.
These are a robot.
Super Friends.
Look at this thing.
Can you imagine if you're sitting there on the street ready to cross and you
look left and you look right and you see this fucking thing running down the
street going 25 miles an hour.
We need to invest in that magnet company,
Asap.
Rocky a magnet to get away from these things.
If we had a shit load of magnets,
magnetic pulse,
just like throwing magnets everywhere to get out of here.
They probably thought that through.
Maybe not.
They're probably using magnesium because lighter.
Whoa.
What is that?
Oh,
that's how it stops.
Twenty eight miles an hour.
Actually a person get out,
run that,
but how long I can not run it,
but like a really fast person.
Can you ride it?
I will take its back.
Choke it.
Yeah.
That's.
Google owns that now high and it pisses battery acid.
So sweet.
I love sweet androids.
Great.
Yeah.
It's just weird like what are you going to do with that?
Why don't you guys make phones?
Like why are you making robot murderer?
We're going to be that thing.
We're going to be that thing slave and 10 more years we're going to be that
thing.
In 20 more years I'll get a download your fucking brain to that and you going to
run to school and the highway remotely.
You're going to be like at home in your bed was going to be like a shallow kitty
pool with wires like the minority report movie.
You're going to be connected to put on your floaties.
Yeah.
You can.
They be connected in this pool with dim lighting with these electrodes on your
head and you're just going to be.
Your consciousness is going to be inside that Cheetah robot just booking down
the four or five and now the cheater lots have meetings whether they want to
keep the humans around any longer.
Eventually I think we're done with them.
Yeah,
once somebody gets stung enough to actually make one of them conscious
themselves,
the beginning,
it's going to be just human consciousness downloaded into a robot,
but then some dummies going to decide,
well,
I want to make my own people and then that's fucked.
Then we're fucked.
Isn't it funny that like we,
we,
we saw like the terminator and all those movies,
like,
that's so stupid.
That's never gonna happen.
Of course it's going to happen
and it didn't stop us.
It's absolutely going to happen.
If you keep going,
what's,
what's going to stop it from happening?
How about that?
Can you tell me if people keep going from here from 2013 with the access to
technology we have now,
how are you going to stop 100 years from now?
There'll be an artificial people.
You're not,
you're not,
you're not.
You know,
there's no way.
There's no way they're going to have that figured out in 100 years.
I mean,
we might not see it,
but our grandchildren are probably see
and uh,
and it,
and we're going to look like idiots.
Chimpanzees,
if they have,
if artificial intelligence has access to like all the information ever,
we're going to look like just fucking moron.
Like these things are dangerous.
They made nuclear power when they didn't know how to shut the plants off,
just built them.
We just started doing it.
The reckless.
They have enough bombs to blow up everything on the planet 10 times over and
they keep making bombs.
They're crazy.
Now.
They have bombs and robots that fly from sky.
No,
they don't need to make the university.
If we got to get rid of freedom ain't free.
Sudden freedom ain't free.
Actually,
I had a guy say that to me in all earnest recently.
Freedom isn't free.
He had it.
Okay.
It is by nature.
Yes,
that's exactly what it is.
Freedom.
It's,
it's free.
It should be free.
See,
that's just because like there's oppression.
That doesn't mean the freedom isn't still a free thing.
Freedom just,
you know,
God damn,
we got to go get the baddies Lee camp.
We do.
Are there any bodies out there or have we created all the baddies?
What do you think?
Do you think it's 50 percent bodies that we've created and 50 percent bodies
that are actually real that we have to go after?
Or do you think it's like 100 percent bullshit
at this point?
You know when you've got history of us propping up military,
military dictatorships and then go in and invading them?
Yeah.
When they're not our friends anymore.
We used to like it,
but now
hilarious.
Another great Bill Hicks bit.
Yeah.
It's just like,
it's so weird that all this stuff is a fact.
All this stuff exists.
You read things like economic hitman.
You find out how we really do,
do run economic,
conventional economic man.
Brilliant book,
the Real,
the real control of resources all around the world.
Like how we get away with it.
And you noticed that one of my videos recently,
uh,
I did it on how basically they found out that what they did,
inventions of economic hit,
man,
I've worked well.
You didn't slave,
you'd save countries with a debt and now they done it.
The American people with student loans and mortgages and shit.
So they've been slaved.
The American people with debt.
Well you say that,
but I say they gave them the opportunity for a nice car camp.
There's something about going to a job in a nice new car.
And if you just put a $100 down at $1,500 alone,
aren't that smart?
A lot of them you say that Lee camp.
But I think that Alexis can make you feel better,
I think.
I don't think I was arguing at camp.
I think that having that loan I was arguing to students,
student loans.
People think they can pay them off and then they can't for 50 years.
That's another thing.
It's like I believe that education should be available and free to all of our
people.
I think it should be one of those things that we encourage.
We need more smart people,
more smart people,
more educated people equals less losers.
That's,
that's a better society.
It's a better we will be better off,
but God damn the idea that you go to school and it costs you a quarter million
dollars by the time you're out and you're fucked,
you're making $50,000
and you and you made that decision at 18 and then your 24 realizing you don't
want to be a lawyer anymore.
Oh fuck.
You're fucked.
And it's a shitty feeling to like you.
You're trapped.
You're sucked into the web of the system.
I mean,
I have friends that have student loans that are just mind boggling.
He talked to them about it.
Like,
how are you going to pay it off?
I'm never going to pay it off.
You really know.
You're never going to pay it up like you,
you have.
Um,
no.
I said thank God I,
I pay as I went.
Oh,
it's so crazy.
Some people,
especially if you do like medical school or something crazy law school,
it's very expensive.
The,
the number,
the actual number you are you're in the hole for before you even get started in
the game of life.
And now there's all these fraud schools that trick people into thinking they're
going to get some great degree and it's gotta be a better way than that.
It's gotta be a way to have education free.
It seems like the most important thing.
Education,
healthcare,
police,
the Internet,
pretty much the newest education.
If you could focus and make sure you're like,
just sit there and try to learn different techniques on like youtube and beyonce
and that's just now I think the,
uh,
the real internet.
I was listening to this podcast,
I forgot that I think it's radio lab until radio lab or something like that.
And they were talking about human neural interfaces and that the ultimate goal
is what they're working on right now is there.
We have already the ability to take a phone and answer,
ask a question to the phone,
speak right into it and give you an answer in a couple of seconds.
But there's going to,
they're going to have within a decade,
two decades,
there's going to be one less step.
You just going to have that information,
you just think you're going to get it,
it's going to be there and you know,
it might actually even come in a form of knowledge,
like it won't be a written word that you have to read,
like it'll come in a formal,
there'll be able to break down what our parcels of knowledge and information
because they've already figured out that they can plant information,
they could plant information to brand,
they could plant false memories.
So if they can plant false memories,
that's another scary thing.
If once you take those memories,
you have control of everything before you go to a place like that.
Fucking what was that Arnold Schwarzenegger movie?
Total recall.
Recall,
they hook you up with some machine and you just live like a baller.
That's the matrix.
That's the real,
the real hologram.
But like they have those been the Pentagon has spent millions and millions on
pills that help erase memories is for,
uh,
for soldiers and things.
Well,
they've also tried a lot of shit that didn't work like LSD,
lsd initially.
The idea was that it would be a truth serum that would capture the
enemy,
give them Lsd,
and they would be forced to tell the truth.
Right?
Not so much especially.
They didn't even understand the dosage was fun serum.
They were giving people every on bottles were acid,
drink this and tell us the truth and they would lose their fucking marbles and
then they said,
okay,
this doesn't work for that,
but maybe it'll work for this.
It's probably like one guy who really loved acid and he wanted just to continue
that research.
They said,
how about we do this when our guys get captured,
they'll take acid.
That way they won't be able to divulge any secrets.
So that was doing that.
Those are the two options and then somewhere around the late 19 sixties they
realized they had a problem because acid really permeated the entire culture and
start changing the way people were thinking about opening minds and so many
people that Timothy leary fans were tuning in and dropping out and they were.
People are getting to a point where that was a,
uh,
there was ways to think there was,
you could be a Republican,
you can be a Democrat,
you could be a humanitarian or you could be a psychedelic adventure.
All of the sudden that's an option too.
Right.
And then people were diving into that and they were like,
well,
these people have really good arguments and they obviously are impossible to,
to mind.
Fuck.
And all of a sudden they're against the Vietnam war.
They're against everything.
Yeah.
They,
you know,
like the weather underground.
They wanted to have orgies and fucking blow up the government.
Yeah.
It's,
you get a lot of weirdness when you start throwing an acid into the mix.
So they're like around 1979.
All right,
let's just make all this shit illegal.
It's hard to believe that up until 1970,
everything was legal.
Marijuana was illegal since the 19 thirties.
But besides the marijuana,
like mushrooms,
Peyote,
mushrooms,
uh,
cocaine,
all that shit was legal until 1970.
That's weird.
Huh?
Maybe not cocaine.
I know.
Definitely a psychedelics,
that's what they're going to say about like Salvia cigarettes.
Alcohol and 20 years from now,
10 years,
well,
they've already done it with Salvia and a lot of places,
but I don't think they're going to say with cigarettes,
thank God they make a lot of money from alcohol because they're not getting rid
of that.
As long as they make money.
Yeah,
we need something.
You can't do that.
We're going to be reprogrammed to beat drunk.
Like I want to be drunk right now.
Dink.
And then you know like it's gonna fuck with your brain so your brain thinks
you're drunk.
It's going to be like an on off switch and we're going to start programming.
What I think they're going to do is have like a Jack Daniels Patch.
Slap it on your stomach and you don't have to drink.
You don't get shitty breath.
You just put a patch on your stomach.
It's so much less cool at bars,
solely not quoted on your stomach a little bit.
Someone's trying to find out what the actual drugs were.
Hey Baby,
you want to hang out and put patches on.
You see that Kanye west a remake video that a seth rogen did and that,
that other guys,
for instance.
No,
I heard it was really funny though.
Yeah.
Cocaine was one.
Cocaine was illegal until 1970.
You mean legal?
Legal rather?
Until 1970.
Oh yeah.
Freud was picking the.
Morphine was legal.
Codene was legal.
Yeah.
Remember how you used to be able to get cody with Nyquil?
Right.
Oh my God.
I was sick once and I took some Nyquil and I've never felt better in my whole
life.
It was beautiful.
It was a,
it was like a total psychedelic experience.
I don't know if I took too much
or what,
but I remember the seven maybe [inaudible] 98,
somewhere in the nineties when it was still available.
I know do it a stand up comedian that's addicted to this stuff and he used to
work in clubs.
It's like in the eighties and nineties and the club owner would have to go out,
like send a manager out to pick them up,
nyquil bottles of Nyquil,
and then he would go back to his hotel room and get fucked up.
Yeah.
The dude was just a straight up nyquil junkie.
I never heard.
I never had anything like that and was working at rascals in New Jersey and they
were telling me the story about this dude and I'm like,
how many bottles?
Like he'll go through three,
four bottles a night.
Yeah.
We used to do that and then no dose if we want at a high piles of Nodoz and just
take it at the same time.
Like,
no,
no.
Like if we went to either a higher low nodoz or road trip,
confused the fuck out of your brain,
son.
Yeah.
You can't be mixing it up.
That's a speed ball for retards.
Yep.
Take both of them.
But cody was delicious.
It was so good.
Like how it made you feel like I was melting into my bed.
I was like so happy.
I was so like I felt so warm and comfortable and I was sick as shit.
It was this back before you're doing anything?
Drugs?
Yeah.
You wouldn't see what you were just on coding.
Nyquil?
I just did it once.
I mean literally only took this stuff once.
Is that John Mayer?
No,
it's a James Franco.
James Franco and Kanye western music.
No,
no,
no.
The one on one.
One on the right is a parody.
Yeah.
Because it was such a ridiculous video that Connie is like pretty much having
sex with,
uh,
what's her dashing on his motorcycle.
So they did a shot by shot remake of it with Seth Rogen as Kardashians.
So bad though.
Like
this fucking the lyrics are so bad.
Yeah.
They just such dumb nonsense,
overinflated ego nonsense.
Did you see him on.
They brought it back on South Park.
I'm the last one was the gay fish one and they brought him back this time.
A hobby?
Yeah,
as Kardashians.
The hobbit.
And she's like,
ma'am,
I have.
It's not a hobby,
but it's a.
am I crazy or did Connie?
She used to be a rational human being.
Like he just wasn't famous enough for them to really bloom.
Shot this terrible piece of shit.
It's pretty funny.
They start making out.
It's not good enough to just to have enough.
It's not good enough to stop it.
Shut it off.
No,
I get it guys.
Just so bad.
I don't get it.
It'd be someone tried to explain to me the,
Oh,
this is another thing that's really cute.
I'm liberals really left wing.
People have taken to defending Kanye,
saying that he's a genius.
The white guilt comes out in full blast.
Yes,
I've read.
Actually I've read.
So they,
they loved him for that moment where he said,
Bush hates black people after Katrina.
Well,
if you want some street cred,
you know,
you uh,
you talk about how Kanye west is a genius.
He's a misunderstood genius.
And like all genie sissies.
What do you,
he misunderstood genius.
How many records you sell?
He's,
he's an understood genius apparently.
Yeah.
Well understood.
And the fact he's criticized.
The reason why he says such things,
it's because he's a genius.
Geniuses are unhinged.
But the problem is the music's terrible.
So that evidence doesn't hold up.
Why is it sell so much?
The same reason why the recent Gallup poll said the 46 percent of the people
thought the earth is less than 10,000 years old.
Okay.
We're overwhelmed by retards.
We're,
we're swimming up.
Yup.
And whatever.
Whatever shit is put on the radio,
the most will sell the most.
So whatever record companies with,
it's getting to put it on the radio every 10 seconds.
Not only that,
now that he's locked up with Kim Kardashian and he's involved in this fucking
weird sort of a,
you know,
a reality.
Yeah.
It's like a metal reality.
It's this,
this,
this weird meme at this internet thing where everybody's talking about and it's
constantly keeps up.
I mean,
that baby is born an actor like that is a role.
That is a role that babies playing other poor kid.
Oh,
just grow up like that in front of the camera.
Completely confused.
Why are the cameras by me?
I went to Bobby's house.
There's no cameras.
Shut up.
You have to get fixed.
And what's it named?
Siberius Lord of the jungle.
What's not on something?
I'm just wondering what they named it.
Oh,
northwest,
of course.
You know,
poor kid.
What are you to do?
Hopefully they'll wake up.
Hopefully somebody will give us a mushrooms and they'll go,
oh my God,
what am I doing?
What have I been doing?
Who am I?
I'm sorry.
Beyonce.
His new album.
It's high.
Who gives a fuck?
Dude,
I don't care.
So it's nonsense.
Pop Music Talk.
Have you heard the New York?
No,
I'm not going to.
It's Shit's pretty much slapped.
I don't want to.
Might Cherry Song.
Got Squirting.
Find it.
What?
Yeah,
it's ship or something please.
It's hot.
It's not hot.
It's dumb.
It's dumb music because I don't like that mood,
but you don't listen to music.
Like what kind of Shitty music?
What does that one pop band that you like?
One direction or.
Not one direction,
but it was something.
It was all shit.
Are you talking about Brian?
There was something recently that you said that you really liked.
I can't remember what it was,
but it was some kind of.
But you got to remember it.
If you've got to bring it up in a conversation.
I failed at that,
but I'll try to remember.
I don't want to be talking about music or actual vapid.
It's so incredibly vapid.
I mean,
I just did a show with a great bangle,
rooftop revolutionaries because they say something and God forbid a band should
say something.
Well,
you know the problem with people saying something if I already know what they're
saying,
I get it.
You know,
you're saying something.
I already know it.
Why did you say Miley Cyrus?
Because you were talking about how much you like Miley Cyrus.
I said she's got a great voice.
She,
she,
when she was singing that Dolly Parton Song joely.
So you,
do you think Miley's better than beyonce?
As far as like the way she's saying in that song?
Absolutely.
Okay.
What do you okay in?
No,
that's an interesting.
I was an interesting.
I never thought that beyonce would.
I never thought my would better than beyonce.
I
like Miley,
but I don't think he's terrible
dog shit song that she said at the American music awards or video awards or
whatever it was.
We got all the controversy.
Yeah,
that was terrible.
But that one video that she did what she did,
the Dolly Parton thing.
She's got a fucking hell of a voice,
man,
you know,
and I guess beyonce does too,
but I don't like that music.
You know,
you should check out the new one it sounds like too,
but thanks.
What's that girl?
That life is short.
Joey ideas likes diet and Diana Ross or that one's sexy girl from the seventies.
That sounds like that kind of music now.
Like she's very sexy,
very seventies kind of a cool album.
I think you would like man.
Diana Ross.
I didn't.
Okay.
Did you see this thing
about Fdr has been going on the Internet lately that FDR grew up in a dress?
Yeah.
How does that then apparently it was like normal back then for kids to what?
What,
what are you saying that?
Yeah,
I was just agreeing with you.
Yeah.
It was normal for people to wear dresses like per,
for people to really.
People are just fucking their children.
They would have their sons and dresses like they weren't so rigid about their
gender roles back then.
Yeah.
Actually photos are and address.
Yeah,
I mean somewhat google,
Google debunked.
Okay.
FDR and address debunked because maybe it was a joke
and we're being.
Well,
I know back then it used to be cute for it didn't matter if it was a boy or
girl.
You dressed them up in a dress because it was cute because our babies.
I don't know about that man.
Nope.
You can't debunk it.
FDR dropping address.
Wow.
This is the article that I tweeted from the Atlantic and said it was wasn't
always blue for boys and pink for girls.
It's fucking really strange.
You don't think about it,
but that was.
That was like not that long ago
and people apparently on a regular basis just to kids up like the crest jesser
boys up like girls and nobody thought anything of it.
The new deals mastermind.
Unexpected childhood look as a reminder that our culture norms about gender
specific clothing for children are surprisingly recent.
Historically historical development,
Huh?
It's kind of weird.
You know,
it is weird that we decide like the ladies on Fox News are allowed to wear these
skirts and loud to have these legs exposed,
but men are not.
We have to wear our silly close,
but if we were in Africa were Maasai Warriors,
we'd have to dress differently.
You know,
we just accept the societal paradigm.
Yeah,
we accept some weird shit.
Why can't FDR being addressed?
Brian?
I think it's cute.
He does.
It's very cute.
I think I was trying to find more pictures of it because uh,
actually I think my mom told me that a long time ago and I didn't believe her.
And then I found out that there's like a lot of old pictures and paintings and
boys in dresses and I started collecting them.
How do you know it's a boy though?
Could just be really looking at this one.
I know boys in dresses.
Um,
are you looking at your phone?
Dude,
we can check it out of this.
No,
I was,
I was looking at tweets
about the show.
You can't do that.
All right.
Do it while it's happening.
They'll suck you in our religion.
You'll never escape.
Okay.
I didn't know that rule.
And then they'll ask you questions and then you respond to,
you guys all got your computers.
I feel left out.
Well,
it's just because we were given each tried to talk about that's how we met
because there's certain things that are going on in the news
thought were fascinating.
I knew I was going to bring up so I had to.
Well,
I'm,
one of the things I wanted to talk about was,
um,
the,
the FDA is actually saying now the antibacterial soaps may not curve bacteria.
They're also saying that like washing your hands in hot water doesn't do a
goddamn thing and that it's just,
it's soap that kills bacteria and that antibacterial soap is actually bad for
you.
And.
But the Purell Shit
does kill like all the bags.
That's not antibacterial soap.
Right,
right.
That's just poisoned.
Right.
But it's also making it so that we don't have any defense mechanisms anymore.
Well,
it is on your hands if you're one of those Howie Mendell type dudes,
that shit in your hand every day.
Yeah.
Some people do that.
They get obsessed with it.
Being blue should shut that heater off man,
because it's,
it's about 150,000 fucking degrees in here.
It's great.
Soon we'll have really.
Um,
but uh,
what they're saying is that we were using it way too much and that,
uh,
people that are doing that or they're killing their natural skin flora and uh,
that it's,
it's not preventing us from getting sick.
We're gonna run into some like bat anti biotic resistant strain of something
soon that's gonna fucking tear us up because apparently it's,
it's caused by like factory farms.
They pumped those animals full of shit so they can live like on top of each
other and something vicious is gonna come up soon.
Most likely,
right?
If we keep fucking around with the ecosystem,
it bounces back like,
yeah,
all these dead bees,
man.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing man.
That the amount of oil that's,
that's probably the GMO crops where they think that they think that that has
something to do is actually an artist.
Cool.
Um,
uh,
from my twitter feed the other day from a Seattle organic restaurants.com,
whereas just talking about the pesticides manufactured by Bayer and Syngenta,
94 percent of GMO corn in the u.
s is treated with either while we listen to this word,
Imo,
Dac,
glow printed or clothing and it didn't.
Oh,
I love that stuff on my pasta.
That sounds good for your corn.
Corn Tastes Yummy.
This guy did this thing where we put a square box and he counted all the
biodiversity inside of it for like 24 hours in different parts of the world and
there's tons of,
you know,
24 hours you find all kinds of insects and all kinds of shit.
Flowers and anything.
You put it in a cornfield in Iowa or whatever and like over 24 hours he found
like three insects or something because it kills everything.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's the way you can grow that corn and nobody eats it.
You gotta just jacket full of all kinds of wacky stuff.
Yeah.
They say that also cell phone signals or messing around with bugs that it's a
beat.
A bees communicate with a some sort of
a frequency that gets interfered with by cell phones.
They can pick up on that.
So when they're flying around,
they hear the transmissions,
they feel them,
and then it diverse.
So now bees are listed in our phone calls to grow.
God dammit.
So bees looking at cocktail
appease affected myself.
Am I on top of their head also while they have those multiple facet eyes?
It's a lot of eyes.
Yeah.
They have eyes that are like,
like pull up a bi because they're pretty trippy when you see them in real life.
Yeah.
There's a.
That was uh,
that was a concern a few years ago that was started.
They were starting to.
I'm trying to figure out what was causing the bees to a drop off and they
thought it was killing him,
but they say they're not killing them.
They're pretty sure that cell phones aren't killing bees,
but they're definitely disturbing them and they're definitely,
I'm fucking with their ability to communicate and people don't realize that when
the bees are gone,
we're in a lot of trouble.
Yeah.
Have you seen those crazy little artificial bees at Monsanto's created?
I heard about him.
I didn't.
I didn't say anything.
Just as weird as the drone thing.
Tiny drones.
The drone bees.
The idea is create something that can do the work of a bee.
Yeah,
because apparently they'll rent beehives and you gotta like someone will bring
it out to like pollinate your shit.
That dragon fly eyes.
See these are probably from the future and this whole time these are like just a
little drones recording us.
Hologram.
See?
Would it be.
I was a hologram world.
Yeah.
They're so fucking strange.
I mean we're just looking at them as if they're normal because we see them
everyday and they are part of our life,
but if we didn't know about bees,
they didn't exist.
Then all of a sudden there was bees everywhere.
We'd be like,
what the fuck?
Those things.
It's weird little things that can sting you and fuck you up and if you're one of
those poor people that's allergic to bee stings,
that must be terrifying.
Go into a field and everywhere you go you could die.
You know you can get stung by some country,
little bug.
It literally shuts your heart down.
There's something beautifully ironic about the fact that a lot of us can't
survive in a field anymore.
It's true.
Kenny peanut butter cancer having to field can't smoke weed.
Oh Wow.
That's so strange.
It looks like technology.
It doesn't.
That look like.
Well,
it also looks like it looks like it's fractal,
you know,
like all those pine cones and you know when you see a sunflower seeds,
like sunflower seeds inside of it at all.
It looks fractal.
They all,
they all look like,
you know,
like it's all.
I'm like a geometric pattern.
Million years of evolution.
So weird.
So weird that they developed eyes like,
you know,
we developed eyes like this and then there's also shit that developed eyes like
us,
but completely outside of us like mollusks octopus.
Their eyes are very similar.
Squids and octopus octopus are incredibly smart to allegedly taken like
heightened shells and things to use tools and shit.
Too bad they are delicious.
They can also climb out of a fish tank,
walk across the floor,
climate to another fish tank,
eat the fish.
Then climbed back to the other fish.
Yeah.
It was a famous story about a guy who had these expensive fish is exotic fish in
the aquarium and one aquarium had octopus in it and one aquarium had these
really expensive fish and the fish would come up missing and the guy was like,
what the fuck is going on?
Like someone's stealing my fish.
So he set up a security camera.
It's like trying to figure out if someone snuck into his house and stole his
expensive fish because it kept happening.
So then he watched this octopus lift up the lid.
If it's aquarium,
climbed down the glass,
I guess they can hold their breath for a long time,
walk across the ground,
walk over to the other one,
climb inside of it,
the fish,
eat it and go back.
Tell me.
It was wearing a top hat.
Yeah.
Uh,
on the,
on the category of weird animal shit.
You should look up the chicken that lived for a year and a half without his
head.
Oh,
I did see that.
Have you seen that?
Yeah,
they had a piece of it,
the just the brainstem.
So it was completely headless.
A year and a half and he took it to a university because everyone thought it was
a hoax.
How'd they eat?
How they had to rip shit into its neck.
Mountain goats are insane.
Look at Italy.
They're like super high up.
They're just climbing sideways off the Damn Damn.
Yeah.
Mountain goats.
They have actually these really rough but flexible toes,
so they.
They grab a hold of rocks and they can get that.
They can walk on shit like easily that we could never walk on a spider.
Go Nature.
Use Crazy motherfucker.
You nature is weird.
It has a lot of options.
Figures out a way,
which is one of the more reprehensible things about our denial that these
dolphins and orcas are intelligent beings just because they're different than us
and that's why we get away with that kind of slavery
from
what led you to become.
To go from being like this,
besides that one.
Fox News appearance,
but to go from being this guy who's got an act and you know,
fairly digestible and then you go,
you know what?
I saw.
I got to say something.
All right,
this is.
We're dealing with,
I'm not satisfied with this anymore.
Like what?
Yeah,
yeah.
I,
I mean,
I think it started with the Iraq invasion,
uh,
that kind of started to wake me up and then it just kept increasing and I woke
up more and more and you know,
reading,
reading a lot of great books,
Chomsky and hedges and Shit and uh,
uh,
yeah.
And it,
it infuriated me to the point where I was like,
I got to talk about this shit on stage.
I don't know,
it was,
it was a lot,
a lot of anger and,
and uh,
how many years in what you doing comedy before he started doing that?
Um,
I mean it probably been like six or seven years,
but not all of those were full time,
so probably only like three full time and then,
but now it's,
it's been a bunch of years.
So we're just starting out in New York.
No,
I started out in Richmond,
Virginia,
University of Virginia and uh,
then right after college moved to New York City.
Yeah.
So you started doing standup in Richmond?
Yeah,
I open mics and uh,
and at Uva I would,
uh,
you know,
open for whatever fucking acts came through Darrell Hammond and Jimmy Fallon and
stuff.
Wow.
Was that terrifying that you probably went through?
That makes sense,
right?
Yeah,
it was.
Well,
it was terrifying also because I was not like a,
I was not a performer.
I had never been on a stage in my life until I decided to do stand up and
wow,
that's wild.
So you do that for six or seven years and then the Iraq war comes around and you
decide to do the kind of actor you do it now where it's all like social
commentary and
yeah,
it was a slow process because I feel like,
I mean,
you know,
you talk about that Shit and you know this well,
like you talked about the shit and you're going to alienate some of the crowds
to figuring out how to,
how to make them happy enough that they're not,
that you don't lose the crowd is it,
you know,
it was a slow,
slow learning experience and it kind of moved over more and more and more until
now.
It's probably 90 percent about,
about world issues and shit.
Yeah.
World is,
she's mad.
God Damn you.
And especially if you're a woman,
if you're a woman and you're trying to have a political opinion on stage,
good luck.
Yeah.
There's so many shithead men that don't want to listen to a woman that has a
different opinion.
No,
do
no doubt.
Because as it like,
there's a subconscious thing that goes on where the audience does like kind of
doesn't want to lower themselves by allowing the comedian to be funny.
And so,
especially with a woman,
you got dudes in the audience watching a woman,
they don't really want her to be funny because it's kind of lowing lowering
yourself and,
and,
and so the way that that's easiest to achieve is I'm a slut or whatever,
and then they're,
the men in the audience are like,
oh,
okay,
yeah,
that's like the best way.
If you don't go with the on the slot,
you better be hideous looking now.
You better be just some giant fucking frying pan faced,
nonsexual,
you know,
I mean to be like a really attractive woman and be a stand up comedian boy,
a lot of.
I shouldn't generalize because there's people that break every mold,
but it's this,
it's a hard road that's hard.
That's a hard fucking road.
Certainly be done.
It's just difficult.
I always said there's like three,
um,
three categories that uh,
your standup goes through.
Like in the beginning you're terrified to go on stage.
It's just their tools,
they just trying to get laughs at the beginning.
You might not like the joke at all,
but you think it works so you do it because you just trying to get a laugh and
then once you get a little bit comfortable then you start doing shit that you
think is funny shit that you actually would laugh at.
Like you'll laugh at your own jokes,
like this is actually pretty funny,
and then you realize what your own actual sense of humor is and you figure out a
way to express that.
Then and then some people never make this third step.
They don't have to like the greats like Hedberg Steven,
right?
They never made this third step and there's still amongst the very best ever,
so it's not a.
it's not a mandatory step,
but for a lot of people that get to the position that you were in,
they always say,
I decide I want to make my opinions funny.
I want to figure out a way to make the ideas that I think
these ideas that are representative of how fucking silly we are as a society.
Turn them
into not just funny,
but something that makes you an eyeopening funny,
like you go back to work and you express it and then everybody laughs and go,
always fucking right.
That's funny.
Yeah.
I think that third step also takes a full on.
Confidence in what you're doing because you're going to alienate some people and
you've got to be like,
fuck them,
I'm doing this anyway.
Yeah,
for sure.
Especially if they don't know who you are.
Right?
Yeah.
I will.
Once you got a ton of celebrity behind you,
I think it changes a little bit,
but do you find that because of your youtube videos,
you're very popular youtube channel,
does that make the biggest difference for you?
That's like been your sort of blog,
right?
Yeah.
That's been the main thing that's made a difference,
a moment of clarity.
It's called and,
and uh,
started doing that three years ago to 180 episodes in now and uh,
and,
and it's nice because that's like international.
It's like a,
you know,
I can go toward the UK and I'm not,
I'm not saying I get billions of people to come out,
but there's fans everywhere,
which is really good.
Cool.
Just the most incredible thing about the internet.
It's like something like this podcast,
I would have never done this.
Internet didn't exist and aren't you still amazed when you get the fan from
Romania or whatever?
Like I'm amazed at all of it.
I'm amazing.
Anybody's listening this fucking thing.
It's just the whole idea of a podcast is incredible that you need this little
equipment.
Yeah.
And then boom,
it's out there to millions of people.
I do.
I do a podcast too,
but the main thing is the moment clarity videos.
Yeah.
What's the difference between your podcast,
the moment of clarity?
Why?
Why is,
um,
you put more effort into the moment of clarity things.
I put more up
the end of the videos and they're also short the three to five minutes,
whereas the podcast,
I'll,
you know,
talk about issues for half hour.
When you do a solo podcast or just you talking?
It's often sold,
although I will do interviews occasionally,
but a lot of times,
so I always say I'm going to do a solo podcast,
but I haven't done one since the beginning.
At the beginning I used to do solo once.
I used to just have ideas and just.
But it's too much work.
Also,
you got to carry the whole thing.
It's tough to carry a little bird as a few people that can actually cause that.
Oh yeah.
Bill Verge.
Great.
Yeah,
that's perfect for that.
I guess you know like bills,
that type of guy that likes to talk over people,
but bill is the type of guy that has a lot of shit to say about a lot of shit
that maybe you wouldn't give a fuck about.
But bill get angry about something like,
no,
no.
Because what they're trying,
he'll go on these like really long rent.
So it's almost like for him it's perfect because for a lot of people they
wouldn't have that.
Like his sense of humor is so aggressive.
Boston,
you're not fucking me over.
I see what you're doing,
you know,
one of his bits and I love the most,
is he does this bit about all these movies where there's a black team and the
black team has all these odds and all these racist and the white people trying
to keep down the black team.
Like how long are we going to make this movie?
It was one about synchronized swimming or running out of sports.
Yeah.
Like they can't swim.
It's such a good bit.
It's such a funny bit,
but it's one of those things where it's such a bill burr bit,
you know,
and it's such a Boston bit too.
It's like his style is one of my favorite styles.
That Boston aggressive style of comedy.
Yeah.
His Shit's great.
And He.
So that style of ranting about shit lends itself perfectly to podcasts.
Yeah.
It's,
it's.
I mean that's the nice thing about what I do is,
is it still very ranty style?
And so,
uh,
it fits well on podcasts and it fits well and those videos.
But uh,
you know,
it doesn't fit well on late night shows.
Gross man,
you don't need those anymore.
I really don't think people need those anymore.
I mean,
I'm not joking around.
I think they're nonsense.
I think those are just like silent movies,
like the why.
Why are you doing that?
Why are you doing it like that?
That's dumb.
Who would go to see a new silent movie?
I saw the hobbit last night.
It was fucking awesome.
It is in three d,
the dragons.
Incredible.
She's the one before it.
Yes.
Did you like that?
No,
no.
That one.
I felt like it was a bunch of shit happening that was setting this one up.
Do the dragon is worth the price of admission.
So the trailer trailer looked pretty damn good.
Oh,
the dragons to start the fucking movie.
I hope they don't kill them.
And the next one we're seeing the most of it or just like the very end.
You got to get to like halfway to the moon before the dragon comes out,
but there's no bad parts in the movie.
The movie is fun.
It's fun from the beginning to the end.
It's way better than the last one.
The last one to me was kind of flat,
but I think it was just,
there was so much to set up,
but this one fuck and wicked dude.
So wicked.
The dragon is so good.
He talks.
It's so cool.
Who Does the voice?
Uh,
the dude who was con on Star Trek.
Yeah.
Not Ricardo [inaudible].
The original con.
Unfortunately rest his soul.
I don't think he's with us anymore,
but the other con,
uh,
a friend of mine just died.
MMA Guy,
Joe Camacho,
the 41 years old.
I can't,
I can't believe it.
People are dying young some.
And you know what's also weird is he was such good health and he made it to the
hospital.
It sounded like.
It sounded like,
you know,
if you read the report that the wife was said that she woke up,
he was screaming and they called the ambulance.
The ambulance came and then he,
you know,
was announced dead at the hospital.
It seems like with heart attacks you always think,
oh,
you could revive them.
You know,
especially a healthy guy.
Yeah.
I don't get it.
He just fought a couple of weeks ago and he's fighting still.
It was 41 years old.
He ran a martial arts academy that guards in tremendous shape.
I don't know,
man.
That's crazy.
Maybe the government man government is wanting to teach people how to kick ass
when they take over.
So it was bs.
It's fucking bs.
It's antibacterial soap.
Um,
there's a fucking article right here in the front of CNN about vitamins being a
waste of money.
Editorial and Medical Journal says,
yes,
they,
I've heard things that a lot of vitamins I've proven that do much taken in that
form,
taken in pill form.
It says the vitamins industry is based on anecdote.
People saying,
I like this and it makes me feel better.
I said,
Dr Edgar Miller,
I'm professor of Medicine Epidemiologic Johns Hopkins,
you know what the problem is?
A lot of these guys that are saying this,
they're trying to get attention for their work and they're taking these
controversial stances because measuring someone's health and measuring whether
or not they would be healthier and not be healthy based on whether or not
they're taking vitamins is very tricky.
But we know for a fact that vitamins cure a lot of shit.
Scurvy take vitamin C,
scurvy goes away.
You know,
we know for a fact that supplementing vitamins has a positive effect on the
human body.
And apparently there's a lot of good tests for vitamin D.
it's all science.
I mean the reason why we can break these molecules down to individual components
like vitamin A,
vitamin C,
vitamin D is because of fucking sciences,
because they realize there's an effect that each one has its variable.
There are different.
They're different from each other.
The idea that supplements don't do you any good?
I bet this guy is as shape,
but he doesn't exercise,
but he doesn't know his body.
It's nonsense vitamins for sure.
If I can help you.
They.
It says vitamins didn't prevent mortality in any way.
In addition,
what?
Well,
how can you tell?
How do you know if someone would have lived?
They didn't have vitamins and died because he took vitamins or died because they
didn't have vitamins and would have lived.
They did.
You don't.
The only way to do it is to take to people.
Have them live the exact same life.
One guy takes vitamins,
one guy doesn't test their blood along the way.
They have the same life experiences,
same stress,
the same.
You can't do that.
Obviously.
There's a lot of variables when it comes to human health.
Stress,
your lifestyle,
the pollution that you live in.
There's a lot of things,
but to say that the building blocks of the human body,
new nutritional supplements like vitamin A,
D,
C,
b,
12 ones that we know absolutely beneficially about it.
They don't inject vitamin B 12 into athletes because it doesn't help.
They injected because it's awesome.
Like if you ever had take vitamin B,
12 supplements,
it's fucking great.
It gives you energy label.
Some will be at 12.
You spray it under your tongue,
like give yourself a big dose of [inaudible].
It's fucking.
Does it depend on the way you take it in,
like whether it's a pill or a.
well it,
the,
the injectable b12 is the best and there's some forms of vitamin C that's more
easily absorbed by the body.
But what can't be disputed when these guys say,
when they're doing studies and me to you,
it doesn't work.
You can't do a study like that.
What we know for a fact is that people need vitamins.
You need them,
you need them in your food,
you need them,
you need them in your,
your nutrients,
in your food.
You need to have building blocks for repair.
You need to give your body protein.
You need to give your body carbohydrates.
And so we understand all that.
Yeah.
There's a reason why they've broken these vitamins down into individual
components because they know what each one does it.
Yeah.
Well,
in the news,
I mean this is another media thing.
The media loves a story,
like either vitamins do everything or vitamins do nothing.
Because that gets readers,
you know,
oh,
it's a gray area,
or oh,
they probably do something or none of those articles getting read.
So instead you put the article like,
Oh,
this guy says they do nothing.
Yeah.
This is one of the guys
a retort to it.
So they believe vitamins,
multivitamins,
addressing nutritional deficiencies in people.
We don't believe that they're the answer to all life ailments,
such as the editorial suggests,
and I think that's one of the problems with saying that vitamins don't help is
without a doubt.
Nutritional deficiencies are not good for you.
You can live through them and you could live a dollar life,
but if you take good food into your body,
you will feel better.
And the reason for that is nutrients for sure.
You should get it from live food,
from vegetables and from fresh vegetables and fresh meats.
That's for sure.
We should get your vitamins if you can eat a balanced out that way,
but supplementing is better than not supplementing.
It just is.
I mean it's pretty much proven
and,
and we don't always understand what those deficiencies due to our brain.
Whereas physically,
if you could see if you're getting fat,
you can see if you're getting out of a,
you know,
unhealthy or whatever,
but,
but brain activity intelligence,
like we can't see that.
So we don't know what eating all this shit does to our brain.
No doubt.
I mean,
you want to really clean up your body.
You want to really be healthy,
cut out the processed food first,
just cut out all that stuff.
If you can cut out,
cut out all the stuff.
That's not just natural things that animals have been eating forever,
like vegetables and meat and eggs,
all the normal stuff.
As soon as you cut out all that stuff.
Even dairy.
I've started cutting out dairy.
God dammit.
I was listening to Tony Hinchcliffe the other day and I was like,
I don't want to cut out dairy,
but if you do
you feel better.
Super Twink,
super twitches.
New Name.
Don't refer to them as anything.
Other than that.
He's happy with it.
I was going with it.
Didn't we get like this country got crazy into like milk and dairy after like a
lobbying campaign when it.
Was that what it was?
I think so.
I think like in the fifties and sixties,
like milk,
like dairy farmers said,
hey yeah,
give you a glass of milk everyday of the week or whatever every morning,
but I feel like we weren't as big into it before that
maybe.
I mean,
it makes sense.
Totally makes sense.
It makes sense that they would try to,
uh,
try to do that.
I mean,
look,
they,
whenever there's a way to make more money,
if there's a way to make money,
that's what they do.
Can we make more money by pretending people need milk?
Let's fucking a glass of milk a day.
It's shown to make your children grow an extra entry here.
You know,
back in the old days they would talk about pall mall loves being our pall malls.
Being the cigarettes at.
Yeah.
I have that poster up in my office.
It was like a four out of five doctors love camels or whatever.
And that was our parent's lifetime.
They were the fifties,
maybe sixties.
When was that fits in?
No,
not even that long ago.
Well,
I was born in [inaudible],
67.
My mom was 21 when I was born,
so she lived in the fifties.
She saw that shit when she was a kid will get this,
blow it in her face and she'll follow you anywhere.
Blow it in her face.
Oh my God.
It's a low joke.
They had a low joe,
but what is that?
I don't even know what that is.
It's a cigarette.
Yeah,
but see if you can find the.
The cow,
the doctor Pall Mall.
Dr. Ads.
That's what a Johnny Carson used to smoke until his lungs became these black,
shriveled up things dangling from his neck rattling around inside of his
wheezing chest.
More Dr. smoke camels than any other cigarettes though it says,
look at
that.
That's so crazy.
They used to do that to watch those old movies or someone go to the doctor and
the doctor would be smoking cigarettes in the office.
Yeah.
Well,
look at this for 30 days.
Test camels in your t zone throat.
I saw another poster that showed the like,
it's like it's good for your teeth.
Zone your throat.
Oh my God.
What was the year that Brian?
That's so crazy.
So crazy that that was.
I mean,
it couldn't have been any earlier than the forties or fifties.
That's how quickly things evolve and that's not even 100 years,
man.
That's nuts.
They thought you're supposed to smoke cigarettes.
Do you ever see the.
I'm a J.
Edgar Hoover movie with Leonardo Dicaprio is part of the movie where his mom is
telling him that your doctor's been telling you to smoke to make your more,
to make you more vital.
You need to smoke.
Yeah,
I listen to the doctor.
Amazing.
That's amazing.
Here's the t zone and see it says your,
uh,
your t zone,
which will tell you t for throat.
That's the,
that's the,
that's the page I have in mind.
What the hell is that your t zone with?
How are these people?
Not all in jail.
Seriously.
Oh,
and it's the same.
One of the dudes that was behind some of these campaigns that,
that said,
smoking.
We can't prove smoking harms people.
It's the same dude that's in charge of climate denial stuff.
Yeah.
Same thing.
Just put some doubt in people's minds.
You can't prove it.
How about this?
Santa Santa Smoking,
this thing that we read earlier today about the climate deniers,
the climate change expert,
the highest paid guy was fucking.
I love that.
It's so beautiful.
I mean,
things like that make you wonder about the simulation.
He's like the fake translator.
Find a way to get into the.
Yeah,
we didn't talk about that yet.
That's one of the weirdest things ever on television.
This guy at the Nelson Mandela funeral was not only faking,
being able to translate sign language.
He had done it before and gotten in trouble before end 10 years ago was accused
of murder and this guy has three rape too.
God Damn it.
And he was three feet away from the fucking president.
Yeah,
and no one
translate pretending to translate all these speeches that I
have a full on schizophrenia episode apparently.
Well,
that's what he claims.
that's what he says.
Yeah.
Maybe it's just a con man foot is.
That was an angry group that burned two men to death while he was in an angry
group that burned to mendot death.
Oh,
where you at?
See?
So crazy.
Where you at?
I think people got upset about.
Remember when we talked about that on the podcast?
Why do black people talk on the speakerphone and people why you go see black
people?
Because they do.
I'm just saying nothing wrong with talking your speakerphone,
but do you tell me why the black people talking speaker speakerphone like that?
They do that a lot.
They don't do it as much anymore.
That's kind of dropped off or maybe not as hanging out as many black people and
we talking like Bluetooth.
No,
they would have their phone on speaker so they'd
be standing there.
What's up dog?
We do a man
and then they would talk like the guy would be like,
Yo man,
you know me.
I just telling them.
Yeah,
and you'd be able to hear both sides of the conversation.
They wanted to let you know that they don't hold their phone up through here.
That's the new style.
But people don't.
You think that no white girls do it.
I guess maybe there's nothing wrong with doing it.
Right.
So what if I hear one side of your conversation or two sides of your
conversation?
It doesn't mean fuck all.
To me it's the same thing.
If I hear you talking on the phone,
if you you're having this conversation and I don't hear the guy on the other
end,
it's not better.
No,
it's just a conversation I'm hearing.
It's not a bad thing.
So if you choose to have your friend on speakerphone,
he talked to them and you want the whole world to hear the full conversation.
What do I give a shit?
I don't have a problem with it at all.
It logically,
to me it's just the same as one person talking.
It's not hurting my feelings,
but I think it's weird that black people enjoy that,
that they like to put the phone on speakerphone.
Did so it's like yelling at the movie theaters.
No,
that's rude because yelling at the movie theaters interrupt something for other
people.
Like you go to see smog,
you want to see a dragon talk,
you wanna,
you wanna hear somebody go,
oh,
you don't fucked up now bill ball.
Oh Dog.
Go in that Bilbo dumb motherfucker.
Gonna fry.
You know?
I think that's rude,
but if you're outside the movies here and the movie's out and be like,
Yo,
dog,
that's smog was the shit.
Yo.
You just see that shit be.
Yeah,
man.
That dragon as a motherfucker.
Dude.
Dragon isn't motherfucker to
high five the way he questions.
Bilbo Bilbo has got the key.
Is it bill?
But yeah,
it was built by Wright.
Who's the.
Who's the old one?
Frodo,
right.
The little dude.
Little but the other one when the other ones they wrote it was from the last
one.
Right.
And then bill bowes in the new ones.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's a good fucking moving.
Doesn't solve world problems.
It's not a,
it's not gonna.
Change the world.
It's not gonna.
Make anybody cry.
You're not going to believe for a second.
It's real.
That's my kind of movie.
Yeah.
I didn't go see any depressing movies,
dude.
I don't wanna see.
No,
I can't.
I can't watch that.
Uh,
the one I was talking about earlier,
the Orca and the black one,
I didn't want to watch the fish.
That's real
pressing because that's real life.
That's even to me worse than a depressing movie about a fictional character,
but I don't.
I don't want.
I don't go to the pressing movies anymore,
but I did go see Dallas buyers club,
but it wasn't really that depressing.
It was just kind of crazy.
Is another stock market one,
right?
No,
no.
It's about act,
about the use of act to treat aids patients and about how they just unloaded act
on people.
Human trials of act that dropping like flies.
People using act for cancer medication.
It was killing more people than the cancer was and they.
When AIDS came along,
they're like liquid,
just fucking throw,
act out and we got a bunch of this shit.
Got An infection.
So what was,
what was behind them wanting to use this shit?
They would make money though the movie goes into great detail it and the movie
actually has a disclaimer at the end.
It's quite fascinating.
They talked about the cocktails were act was used in a lower dose and helped
save lives.
Like I said,
it just like as a,
as an aside,
at the end of the movie in print,
again,
we got to say that so we don't get sued,
you know?
Wow.
But the reality of act is act as toxic as fuck.
And Matthew mcconaughey's character gets aids and they put them on act is about
to die and then he starts eating healthy and going to this guy in Mexico who's
been kicked out of the United States practicing alternative medicine.
I don't want to tell you anymore,
spoiler alert,
but uh,
it's pretty interesting,
but it's,
it's the same thing.
It's all about.
You just said,
of course he did.
Is Twelve going on 12?
Um,
I mean it's the same thing.
It's just people making money.
It's just people making money off a drug that kills me.
They don't care.
They're,
the movie goes into really,
really.
They do a really good job of painting how the decisions were made and it's
interesting stuff.
Yeah.
I mean that's the thing.
When there's money behind it,
tilted the craziest shit.
Craziest shit.
Do you have hope,
Lee camp for the human race too?
I have.
Hope,
um,
I think it could go one of two ways.
I think we could,
uh,
we could,
we're,
we're going down a really ugly path right now where things like the corporations
are,
are taking over the decisions that are being made globally and you know,
things like the Trans Pacific partnership,
which is the largest trade deal mankind's ever seen and basically seeds the
sovereignty of our country to corporations and it's being pushed forward right
now.
And so it has that past.
It has not passed yet,
but Obama is trying very hard to make a pass.
And,
and,
uh,
it's being decided by 600 corporate lobbyists and uh,
and not.
They're not allowing the wiki leaks,
leaks,
some of it.
And it's pretty horrible.
Uh,
it basically says that if a corporation can't do something here because of
environmental laws or whatever laws,
they can then sue us in an international tribunal to get their profits.
And,
uh,
and I think that if we keep going down that path,
it's going to be very ugly.
But I think that people are waking up.
What can they do though,
if they really are waking up,
what do you think could be done?
Like if you had to look at the big picture,
if you look at like the society that we've sort of found ourselves in today in
2013,
you sort of extrapolate from there 30,
40 years in the future.
How do you see it all working out?
I mean to make it work out,
we've got a start.
I think we've got to start living differently.
I mean if,
if every country would he use resources the way America does?
We needed,
what were the numbers?
Three,
five,
earth,
something like that to be able to sustain it.
It's we live in an absolutely unsustainable model and,
and you know,
maybe the party will go on for a few more years,
but eventually it's got to end.
And so I think we do have to change the way we live in a pretty severe sense
and,
and it's,
and it's being thrown into our face as we see every day.
You know,
what the fuck.
And the fact that there's a patch of plastic twice the size of Texas floating
the Pacific,
you know,
Fukushima,
all this shit.
It's,
it's kind of
bigger than that now,
right?
Yeah.
It's like that Hg wells quote that I love this quote,
that history is a race between education and catastrophe and know,
get that out when he was writing war of the world.
Hundreds when really they hadn't even begun to fuck the world up yet
and will and,
and that other gray color will do the right thing once we've exhausted all other
options.
I love that one.
That one's great.
That one's fantastic.
You know,
I'm listening to this,
uh,
latest hardcore history podcast right now from you ever listening to Dan
Carlin's,
hardcore history,
no amazing podcasts.
He takes a episodes in history that you would probably never study and makes
them really fascinating and really interesting.
But it's about world war one.
What got us into world war one and how brutal World War One was when the Germans
invaded the Belgiums.
And yeah,
it's hard to really believed that that was 100 years ago.
True history is mind boggling,
mind boggling because what we learned as kids,
it's nothing.
Yeah,
it's true.
Yeah.
You really don't get nearly enough.
There's not enough time.
There's no,
you know,
you got history.
How many days a week,
you know,
how many hours in a day you're in class for an hour at a time.
Like,
what the fuck are you going to learn here?
Take this at home and,
and be even more ridiculous,
you know,
read some pages that you'll never remember and we'll teach you some shit that
we've already disputed.
Like Columbus,
we still have columbus
stay.
Yeah,
I know he's the most evil motherfuckers.
His own his own journals.
Talk about like chopping people's hands and noses off if they didn't bring them
gold,
his own fucking diaries.
If you don't,
if you want to learn about him.
Listened to our podcast with Greg proops.
Greg proops,
drops knowledge.
Ladies,
if you're listening to that podcast is amazing.
He's so smart,
but he's also well read and you know,
it's so entertaining.
So he's talking about Columbus.
It's like one of the best descriptions of how fucked up that those people were.
Yeah.
The scene of them landing,
you know,
in these places where these people had never seen people like that before and,
and also in the diaries,
he's like,
it's amazing how generous they are.
They just walked up and wanted to be friendly or whatever,
and then when they don't bring enough gold,
he fucking.
Yeah,
chops their heads off.
Yeah.
They were all like psychedelic people taken Iowasca and living off the land and
he's crazy.
Assholes came by boat starving to death.
He was raping this thing that I'm listening to about a world war one.
It's really hard to wrap your head around these atrocities taking place today
because that what the Germans did to the Belgiums let me see.
It's like really crazy,
like getting his type shit and the idea that that's the only 100 years ago and
that's the same.
The same animals who would call themselves people today existed.
Then like the form of us and them.
They're the same.
There's no difference.
Maybe we have better nutrition so people like they get bigger,
but other than that,
taller,
well Japanese people,
clearly they've aided.
Nutrition's aided them
that they,
the size of Japanese people since the indoctrination into the western diet,
the they've grown steadily larger and larger and he was up to like,
if you go back to like,
you know,
Rocky Marciano,
who was the heavyweight champion of the world,
he was 180 pounds.
He was like one 89 at his heaviest.
Wasn't big at all.
Do you ever go into like a Ford from the civil war and the door is like four
foot five or something?
Yeah,
old houses you have to duck,
you know,
like people in the civil war,
they weighed like 120 pounds and these great,
you know,
historical figures like A.
I'm a,
I'm saying Robert e Dot Lee,
but I don't actually know how tall he was,
but it's like guys like Robert e Dot Lee or whatever.
They're like five foot tall and you're like,
what?
Yeah,
let's find out.
How tall was Robert?
I bet you're right.
Yeah.
I think Napoleon was
at least he's known as being a little dude because he was a little dude amongst
the little dudes.
Yeah.
How tall was Napoleon?
Let's find out after Robert e Dot Lee.
Okay,
let's check.
Let's say yes.
I say he's five.
Five.
Do you say
five,
four,
one.
Oh,
he was actually five.
10,
zero.
We fucked up.
How tall was the poet?
We fucked Abraham.
Lincoln was Abraham.
Lincoln was huge though.
Okay.
Napoleon,
I say I say five feet tall.
Forty
four.
Eight.
Four.
It.
You don't give a fuck used enterprises,
right?
Shit.
Huh?
This is five foot five.
Hmm.
Wait a minute.
That doesn't make any sense because people were really little back then.
Okay.
Five point five.
That doesn't mean five and a half.
Five and one slash two inches long by 45.
Is it in feet?
Is He Canadian one?
It says one point six.
Eight,
six meters.
What does that fuck is that?
Why would you give me that as Siri?
Oh,
why does it say five?
It says five comma,
five feet tall.
That's weird.
Okay.
This website sucks.
Alright,
let's go on wikipedia.
Okay.
His height was actually.
Here we go.
I was.
How tall was an important napoleon?
Huh?
Listen to this.
The British propaganda of the time promoted the idea that Napoleon was short.
In reality,
his height was above average for the period.
Wow.
That is really.
And through history.
That's exactly what we were talking about.
The stories of now suggests than polling was five foot six,
which was often seen.
Wow.
That's really interesting.
That's not that show for back then.
Yeah.
It says Napoleon was often seen with his imperial guard,
which also contributed to the perception of his being short because the imperial
guards were above average height and psychology.
The Napoleon complex is regarded as a derogatory social stereotype.
That is interesting.
So in reality,
Napoleon was taller than the average person at the time.
They were just learned it here.
First folks,
and we learned it because the Internet,
Lee camp,
see you soon.
That'll be wired into our minds and we will just think it and then everybody
will be an annoying
that has all the answers and you'll.
They'll tell you something like all self righteously,
and you'd be like,
I know that too.
Duh.
Everyone knows everything I do.
Yeah.
That will help.
Right?
When everybody knows everything,
we can't know if everyone knows every.
There'd be no grandstanding.
Be Equally Vapid.
When everybody has all information.
We're also going to be able to tell when anyone's lying.
We're going to know everything about everything,
so there's not any secrets.
It's awesome.
It's going to be weird.
It's going to be.
There'll be a brain scan for lying pretty soon because we want to be on ecstasy
all day.
They're gonna.
Develop a new ecstasy that doesn't fuck with your head so you can just be
annexed to see all the time.
Everyone knows everything,
but no one cares.
Everyone knows everything about everybody,
but everyone's an ecstasy.
So,
like,
so what?
Give me a hug.
You be alive.
So happy to be alive.
Lee Camp.
So,
uh,
when you go back to New York,
I leave tomorrow.
Back to New York.
Yeah,
I,
I've,
uh,
I've enjoyed it out here.
I've had,
I mean,
you know,
whether partially because you gave me a good show at the ice house one time.
I had good shows that a fake gallery.
So yeah,
a lot,
a lot of cool things happen out here.
Um,
he did a great job with the Ice House.
That was really funny stuff.
Funny stuff that,
that crowd is the greatest crowd on earth.
Smart.
They don't get any better.
It just really doesn't get any better.
So it's a club from the 1960.
It spoils you when you,
when you get to deal with smart crowds because then you've played the
neanderthals at a regular club and yeah.
But again,
the Yin and the Yang,
it makes you appreciate those.
I think you should always have a shitty fucking show every now and then just so
you appreciate the good ones.
A bunch of dumb people.
You should probably schedule shows and places you suck just so they could really
appreciate,
like,
you know,
Austin somewhere cool.
Chicago,
you know,
scheduled places that are just fucking fill with.
You're going to get some emails from the places that aren't those cities in
fucking Weirdos identifying with a certain patch of dirt.
There's some cool people
if people want to find out,
but you're standing up there to catch you somewhere.
Where's the best way to get ahold of you?
Elite camp.net.
And then the twitters at Lake Camp and the facebook is Lee camp,
comedian and [inaudible] dot com.
Uh,
yeah.
They used to be.
It used to be very important site.
Well,
if they can't,
I have no idea what it means.
Camp Lee camp makes sense.
I always figured I might go over there one day and they'd be like,
hi,
I'm Lee camp.
And they're like,
that's not legal.
I can't believe you.
Um,
but yeah,
now I do those videos twice a week.
Twice a week.
Yeah.
You're committed.
I am committed.
Holy Shit.
One hundred 80 episodes out there.
Do you ever find yourself just to talk about today?
So it's not.
There's nothing to talk about.
I said,
I don't always know how to make a funny size.
It's fucking depressing.
Yeah.
So everything.
So is that like the theme,
everything has to sort of have a meaning to it.
You've got to be pointing something out and try to make it funny.
Yeah.
Most of the time I stick to pretty important topics.
I will occasionally have some fun,
like with the Amazon drones,
uh,
that's,
that's less important topic,
but most of it's a pretty crucial stuff going on in the world to Amazon drones.
One day we're going to look back.
If people haven't watched that video,
they should watch it.
It's weird that we've shown it on the podcast for the Amazon drone dropping
packages off.
A lot of people,
like the actual science people thought that they were trolling,
they were just trying to get a lot of attention for the possibilities of the
future.
Like in no way shape or form actually preparing to use drones to drop packages
off.
Like that's interesting.
I think the key would be what the flight patterns like are they running into
planes and power lines and I think they're really low.
I think they only go like above buildings and shit,
which makes them easy to shoot down.
We were saying is that someone's going to shoot your package happen if you're
delivering some fucking.
It's something shooting with prizes.
Yeah.
You just make them blow up.
Meanwhile,
they'll have 360 degree cameras everywhere to prevent that because Amazon wants
to secure the safety of their drones and I'm sure if your privacy will have no
interest in the thousands of cameras flying around our neighborhood.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They won't hack those at all.
They're going to realize from this that people need their freedom,
need this space,
and they're gonna they're gonna.
Um,
they're going to give us that.
They're going to
take an agreed this is the positive jail.
Yeah,
man,
this is what I do.
When I in the shot,
I tried to end it on a good note.
I'm going to say Amazon's going to realize that the NSA and all these,
you know,
you need to understand the folly of their ways.
I think people are slowly waking up,
but I do.
I'm positive.
I consider myself a cynical optimist.
I view the glass is half full of Shit.
That's a good one.
I like that.
I agree with you,
I think,
I think it also,
it could go both ways for sure,
but right now the possibilities I think are leaning towards what you're saying
that people are waking up.
People are,
it just takes awhile.
I mean if you look back at what this hardcore history podcast about the world
war one and how brutal the,
uh,
the Germans were to the Belgiums and how,
you know,
that wasn't that long ago and you think of how relatively safe the world is
today,
unless you were in Pakistan,
you get hit by a drone or less.
You're in Afghanistan or a few like severe hot spots in the world.
It's a lot of fucking safety.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot more safety now than it's ever been before.
It's a lot more civility now than it's ever been before.
And all of the bullshit,
all the war and all the,
it has to be done like under an air of fuckery because if you just come out with
the idea of imperialism is not gonna be accepted anymore.
You can't just say like,
the Germans say we're going to take Belgium now.
Like America would go,
well,
why?
Why would you go into Belgium?
They didn't do anything to anybody.
They barely have an army.
Like,
what the fuck are you doing?
We wouldn't stand for it.
Well,
we're going to go through Belgium because we want to get to France.
You can't do that.
Also news get news gets around the world much quicker.
It used to be if you wanted to say somebody did something in that attack them,
you could do it and no one could prove otherwise.
Whereas now their cell phone cameras in frequent Syria showing you what's going
on.
So yeah,
that's also one of the reasons why the idea of false flags,
which a lot of people don't want to accept as a historical fact,
but I mean they of have a history channel talks about the Gulf of Tonkin,
Gulf of Tonkin.
It's declassified documents that fake that shit.
So there's an awareness like after a certain age we're like,
Eh,
yeah,
we fucking lie to you.
Million people died,
whatever.
Whatever we don't do anymore because if it's long enough,
people just don't even notice that the truth came out like,
dude,
that was 60 years ago.
We don't do that anymore.
Okay.
Pay Taxes.
Hippie.
Do you?
Do you think freedom is free?
Because freedom is.
You should make that the motto,
your show for freedom,
freedom and free.
Freedom Ain't free.
Lead camp.net.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Camp.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for having me,
man.
Off.
And they were in California will make you a regular sun.
Definitely.
You're in.
Um,
thanks to everybody that came out this weekend in Sacramento,
a super twink and I had a great day.
It was awesome.
He prefers super 20 or is he loves it.
He loves it.
I asked them last night,
I go,
I heard you're called super twink.
And he goes,
yeah.
And I'm like,
that's hilarious.
He goes,
I like it.
I'm like,
what?
Well,
it's funny and it actually,
it goes a lot and I don't want to give away his act,
but he's got some really funny bits that,
that actually enhances.
And um,
yeah,
he's Vegan.
He's awesome.
He Tony Hinchcliffe is fucking awesome and he'll be with me,
New Year's Eve with Sam Tripoli at the Melrose Improv in Hollywood and we would
like to thank one 800 flowers,
one 800 flowers.com.
Go get yourself a beautiful Christmas centerpiece,
$10 off by using the reference J R,
e Dot.
That's one.
800 flowers and enteredj r e dot.
Go to one 800 flowers.com or call one 800 flowers and mentionedj r e.one of our
newest and best to sponsors.
Everybody loves flowers.
Bitches were also sponsored by on it.com.
Go to o,
n n and it use the code name Brogan and save yourself 10 percent of any and all
supplements.
And finally,
last but not least,
we are sponsored by squarespace and awesome way to make a really easy,
quick,
clean,
professional looking website.
You can do it.
I can do it.
They'll work on IPADS,
iphones,
androids,
and they're new ecommerce product Galapagos,
which allows you to change the images when you hover over it with your cursor.
It's fucking easy and awesome way for anyone to design.
A website,
go to squarespace.com and use the code Joe and the number 12 to save 10 percent
off a limited time.
All right.
We will be back Wednesday with Eddie Wong and,
and Shane Smith.
And Brian's got some shows coming up.
Yeah,
just I just went on Sale Texas tour me and super twink Tony Hinchcliffe.
January ninth,
Houston.
January,
January 10th,
Austin.
And January 11th.
Dallas.
And Dude,
Tony kingscliff is fucking funny.
That kid is really good,
man.
He was really funny.
Uh,
one of the show of Vegas.
December 27th,
probably the greatest lineup I've ever put together ever.
Um,
it's Joey Diaz,
Brian Cowen,
Ari Shaffir and me at the Mirage.
Shit is going to be crazy.
It's the day before the UFC.
Friday the 27th.
Come on down freaks.
Alright,
we will see you guys Wednesday.
Much love,
Big Kiss Lee camp.net hollow hollow.